Oh,
I've heard that.
Yo,
I invented that shit kid.
The Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by the fleshlight.
If you go to Joe rogan.net,
click on the link for the flashlight and entering the code name Brogan,
you will get 15% off the number one sex toy for men.
Isn't that beautiful?
We give out.
That's the bargains.
Decent discount.
It's a fucking solid discount.
It's tangible.
Um,
we're also brought to you by [inaudible] dot com makers of Alpha brain,
the cognitive enhancing supplement.
And if you've heard all my spiel about it,
I'm short and then this shit down cause you know what the fuck it is.
Go to [inaudible] Dot Com oh and an it for all the details.
If you're interested at Google nootropics would,
nootropics are his vitamins that are,
that are made to enhance your,
the function of your mind.
Very controversial and interesting subject.
So Google that shit before you buy anything.
And we offer a 100% money back guarantee on the first 30 pills.
So you don't even have to return the items if you buy it and you feel like this
is not for you,
whatever,
100% money back guarantee,
you don't have to return it.
You don't have to do shit.
Make it yourself.
You do that too.
There you go.
Steal the ingredients and make yourself the ingredients.
Don't fuck it.
That's you're confusing these people.
You could,
but it'd be powdery and shit and it wouldn't feel nearly as good unless you
could be your thing.
But everybody's into different things.
Mommy fucking on it.
Dot Com.
O n n I t checkout all the various supplements that are for sale.
There it is.
Um,
uh,
what is it?
Shroom tech sport.
This the workout one.
A shroom tech immune.
The immune system one.
Of course,
Alpha brain we already talked about,
but new mood.
The shit that you take,
the five HTP enhancing supplement.
You know,
you're still kinda depressed.
You okay?
Out of my mind,
we all are.
We shouldn't be talking right now.
Play the music.
Friends honey.
Honey.
Joe Rogan podcast
through the wonders of the Internet.
We've come together,
these guys.
Um,
there's a guy named balls of steel to thank for us finding out about show them,
that's his name on the Rogan board.
His name is balls of steel and balls of steel sent me this,
uh,
this,
yeah,
I guess was really little.
They're little balls of steel to be rattling around and they don't have to be
big goals to just a little tiny ones.
Probably a lot of tissue.
I barely feel it.
He sent me a message saying this is going to be your new favorite song.
And I was like,
okay,
whatever.
You know,
I don't know this guy.
I've never had any interactions with them.
It sounds like,
you know.
Yeah.
Well I,
you know,
I dunno.
I'm,
he nailed it.
Whatever it is.
Maybe it's just,
it was so good that he just knew that all someone had to do was hear it.
And that sounds like so corny.
I,
it sounds,
it sounds like very showbizzy when,
when you know,
when,
when entertainers compliment each other cause it sounds like some academy award
bullshit or you know,
you know what I mean?
Like when when someone sees someone and it goes,
wow,
you guys are really good.
It doesn't,
does it?
I always go,
yeah,
yeah.
Even if you didn't like him,
you would fucking act Durham,
you know,
you would say like,
hey man,
I just want to tell you I really loved you in that movie.
He couldn't give a fuck about that movie.
You see,
you just say,
I want to really be clear that it's not that and this is the only way to,
you have to bring that up.
It's the white elephant in the room who they are.
Oh really?
Oh what's your last name is Timberlake.
Yeah.
By the way,
when you do that to people,
they know you're doing it to them and they just play it along.
So this dude sends me this link and I go to it and it's you guys on top of a
roof,
I guess like somewhere outside of La says live at the Esquire house.
Is that what it was?
And uh,
it was uh,
the song angel of death and I was like,
Holy Shit.
I was like,
this is like,
it was really originals,
like country Sorta twinkie and had a lot of like a lot of different elements to
it.
It's like the way the songwriting was really original and I was like,
wow,
what the fuck is this band?
So then I go on youtube journey and I just got into your shit and I,
I bought,
um,
Billy Jack on a,
on iTunes and I,
that's all I've listened to for like a fucking week and a half.
I've all,
I'm,
I'm seriously thank you sir.
Was one of the best cds I've heard in years.
It's so rich and so complete.
The thing that freaked me out about it,
it's like,
how the fuck do I not know who you are is so good?
It's so good to me.
It was preposterous that I didn't know.
And it's uncomfortable to say that in front of some people but,
but it was really no one cares about you.
I don't believe it's not,
I don't believe his dad.
I believe you guys are on the launching pad and I think the Internet is,
I think you guys are going to get gigantic just from the Internet.
I really,
I just,
I think this is,
it's inescapable.
You guys are too good and you know,
went to see you the other night and seeing bands live for a comic is so
inspirational,
you know,
for me at least because like when you,
when you go see other comedians that's inspirational too.
But like I already know how to do that.
You know,
I already do that.
When I watch someone do something like music,
I have no musical talent at all.
Nothing I've done or how to play anything.
I don't know how to sing anything.
So for me it's so alien and so I'm watching you guys jam up there and I have no
sense of self in the equation.
There's no,
it's nothing like,
oh,
I don't know if I would play that like that.
Emily Shit,
I don't,
I don't know anything about music so I can just like apes,
just slack jaw like,
oh wow.
It's so to me that one of the most amazing things to watch is a,
a band performed live,
you know,
all you guys,
you guys were fucking amazing.
You guys are really good.
This might be that show Biz thing that you were just talking about,
but it's,
but it's not that cause I feel the same way about standup comics.
I feel like it takes the biggest balls out of any of the performing thing
because if it's not funny,
no one's going to laugh.
You know what I mean?
If we're done playing,
people are going to clap kind of no matter what you do.
And it's like an etiquette.
But if it's not funny people,
you just kind of up there.
Well,
and you're hanging
Joey Diaz,
who's a good buddy of mine are enough to know who he is,
but he,
uh,
he says it best.
He said,
his standup comedy is the hardest,
easiest thing you'll ever do,
and what he means by that is that it's really hard to get funny,
but one of you funny.
Then everything's easy.
Then you know how to a long as you stay in the frequency,
then you can,
you know,
you know what's up.
You know you know how to do it.
You know how to do it right.
You've got to just make sure you're completely concentrate on what you're doing.
Never disrespect the relationship you have to the audience.
As long as you get to a certain level,
you can do it fairly easily.
That's what it means.
But getting to that level,
it's like there's a lot of shit that happens.
It's a long process.
Do you go,
I mean,
do you go off your material and just kind of riff or you sticking?
Yeah.
You have to see that,
that that freaks me out.
That's my favorite time.
I love it when we're off the track and in the woods.
I love it.
This is one of my favorite times.
I love hecklers.
I secretly love hecklers.
I don't want them hurt their feelings,
but I love when Shit happens.
I just love the chaos of the moment.
No,
just I think,
I think that's like where it's at.
Those the people that can can go off track and you know,
just bounce back and throw it in there and it being something that's totally off
the cuff because everybody knows when it's,
it's just repetitive leap.
This is a little of that.
Well you know what,
also people know when it's stale,
you know that the key to comics is,
you know,
you can only,
you only keep your stuff for a couple of years and you've got to just launch
into orbit.
You know,
like you guys like you'll,
you'll be playing la river for fucking decades.
That's on this amazing,
you'll be playing that when you're an old lady.
She used to buckle up.
Then when you're an old lady,
that song is awesome.
It's going to exist forever.
We will be just like old bits that I have man,
where they were like my best bits at a time.
I can't even touch them.
They're useless.
Well think time.
Time.
Just change.
Well,
it's not even an area.
It's just,
you know,
you can't just do your old Shit and then you forget how it goes.
And I stopped doing it for a while and you forget how it goes.
Like someone will yell out something and I'm like,
good luck with that one.
I don't even know how that one goes.
We do the same thing,
songs that we don't put,
like when you're on tour and you play the same set over and over every night and
every once in a while you'll throw on a,
you know,
a different tune if you're feeling crazy or intoxicated.
And um,
you know,
people make a request and every once in a while we'll be crazy enough to play
it.
And there's been many times where I've forgotten the words.
And you Christina Aguilera it seriously,
it's Christina.
She loved that with the Superbowl though.
She did the national anthem and she fucked up the lyrics.
You forgot about that.
I'm just kidding.
That's tough though.
I mean,
you're playing in a stadium.
Listen,
that bitch is tripping.
I didn't know she's tripping.
I know she's tripping.
I don't know what it is.
I don't know what she's doing to get by,
but it's not green tea in yoga.
There's a lot going on there.
We stand with.
Christine had PTA.
She had period blood running down her statement that she was so horrifying.
Photo.
Have you seen this?
All that shit up.
Yeah.
Pull it up.
You need to pull it up.
Christina Aguilera period.
Blood down,
leg photo.
[inaudible] shirts not face.
I'm not,
I'm not kidding.
Someone tried to say it was spray on Tan like what are you trying to make her
asshole look like midnight?
That's ridiculous.
No Way.
It could be that kind of volume.
I'm so scared.
It's don't be scared.
It's life.
It's part of life.
Christina,
I'm sure it's a good
girl.
She's got a beautiful voice.
I'm not into that guy's singing cover.
It's got a powerful voice.
Very pretty girl.
She's hot as fuck.
What was that dirty song that you had back in the day?
Is that what it's called?
It's pretty cool.
Ready
and I'd like to again,
conmigo Charles a freight and come on over.
Okay.
Can I say that?
I definitely think that's a spray on Tan.
Brian,
look at how fucking rich and red that is.
I dated a girl that gets that shit done every three days and it forms a river.
It comes down your leg.
It's exactly like probably what it is.
Listen,
I'm going with period blood.
Fuck you assholes.
Party moving bitches.
Listen man,
that's so funny.
I don't think it's spraying onto,
that's period blood bro.
Dude,
that's your ass in the background.
Joe Behind us.
No,
couldn't be no wait,
meatier than that bro.
My ass is so much media.
That was sprint.
That was spring break.
2004 show back in the day.
Joe Joe was in myrtle beach.
Oh my God.
Do I gotta do gotta get by?
What?
So,
um,
you know,
meeting you guys,
um,
through Twitter is like a,
this is like a,
the first time I've ever met a band through Twitter and then had the band come
on the show,
you know,
this is,
this is a very interesting phenomenon.
I mean,
these are really strange times we live in.
It really is because if we lived in another era,
I would have to hear,
but you guys in the radio and then,
uh,
there's no way I would meet you unless I ran into you somewhere.
You know,
I can't just tweet you and go,
holy,
you guys,
you guys are the shit.
Can't do that.
You know,
that bizarre thing.
Very bizarre.
But back then,
you know,
I think about this a lot back then there was probably,
while I'm pulling this out of my ass,
but for every hundred thousand bands,
I love wood.
That was my answer.
Exactly what it sounded like.
He'd probably like a 10th as many bands,
you know what I mean?
So you have a better chance maybe,
I dunno,
that doesn't make sense.
That's true.
Mathematically.
Or they're more balanced that I think there's,
who's responsible for that Internet?
Yeah,
the Austin,
Texas.
Only the Internet is in Texas with this horse.
Yeah.
I'm in Austin,
TX,
populating.
Ever listened to the,
you see,
they have like public access and they have like,
you know,
local bands are constantly playing in public access.
A lot of bands in Austin,
Texas.
This is the truth.
You guys are from uh,
Ohio.
Cleveland.
Yes.
And where are you from?
I'm from New York.
He,
Massachusetts area couple of York.
Well,
you know,
I lived in New York a couple of places,
the city upstate and then I lived in Massachusetts as well.
We met in la though.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
Cool.
And you guys met,
uh,
how'd you meet?
Did you meet like we use a class or some shit?
Yeah,
that's sort of aftermath.
Tell everybody your names.
I'm Suzanne Santo.
My name is Ben Jaffe and uh,
we are,
hey honey,
honey,
honey.
It that like you,
you've sort of like,
you know,
you're saying all these great things about our band and like,
you,
you orbit around this,
this,
you know,
world,
this community of,
you know,
like,
uh,
UFC fighting and all this crazy like,
you know,
you're talking about Christina Aguilera's period,
block
and work all honey honey.
And it's,
you know,
it's commendable for you to embrace us with open arms with such a
nipple juice softy.
I'm a Softie,
you know,
I really am.
I'm,
I'm wrapped up in a lot of other crazy shit,
but,
um,
I'm trying to be as nice as possible.
One of your fans made fun of Our Name on Twitter,
but we fucking his,
yeah,
probably hates his life.
There's a lot of people on Twitter that hate their life.
You know what?
There's a lot of people out there in the world that just want to scratch.
They just want to reach out and clock.
Nobody took care of them.
Why?
Because it's a complicated cycle of life and it doesn't make any sense.
And everybody's got a place and you don't even necessarily want to be in that
place,
but you're stuck through circumstances.
I'm no good.
You know,
we,
we worked it out.
That's not worth it.
Listen,
you keep doing that.
Keep doing that.
You'll never no time for anything else.
Yeah.
You'll have a,
well honey,
honey is top performing,
but they're full time.
Get a tweet.
Looks all they're going to do be,
he'll be less of a dick now.
Maybe there's a chance.
Yeah,
maybe.
Maybe.
Did you just say like re reply,
hater,
hater?
No,
no,
no.
He basically,
yes.
He was like,
hey Joe,
why don't you ask him where they came up with such a god awful band name?
You responded.
I responded.
I just very sensitive.
I'm going to help you guys in our band name was inspired by your mom.
Oh.
Oh,
hi.
Yeah.
We really,
that shut him up,
but yeah,
we decided this is Mama.
He didn't even know.
You could have been a dude that said that.
Maybe you just spoke his language.
Yeah,
that's what I was hoping you would say.
Yeah.
Let's keep going with this,
which is totally fucked up.
Yeah.
Well that's a lot of the world.
I was hoping you'd say you boom my mind.
Oh yeah,
that's you're hoping it would be crazy.
That's what he is.
Yeah.
See,
I'm already in trouble.
Role playing.
I was role playing,
right?
You can't.
You gotta learn how to deal with trolls.
This is a lesson that,
this is a good point.
It's good that you came to us before you guys blow up because we're going to
help you tremendously because going to be a line of people and they,
they're,
they're what's called trolls.
You know what trolls are writing on the Internet,
the mythical creature.
No,
no,
no.
They're the people that are real.
And what they do is they say things to try to get you to respond.
All you have to do is respond.
They'll go,
oh,
trolled you.
This is how low and the game is.
The game is so low end.
It's like say anything mean anything horrible,
anything ridiculous,
anything preposterous,
anything accusatory.
Lie,
make up shit.
Point out things that are completely our Twitter Sensei and I'm a help you.
I'm going to help you.
And all they're trying to do is get you to go,
what the fuck?
Who are you?
And they're like,
Yay.
That's all they want you to do.
They want you,
they want to get a re a green light.
We want to get a green light.
So they might send out,
they might send Jose Conseco a thousand tweets.
You know what's funny though,
day when I did it and I felt overly emotional and maybe that's great,
is don't,
don't,
uh,
maybe I should like Twitter off when were boozing,
the real issue is there's too many people that you're going to interact with in
your individual one on time.
It is impossible for one on one time to interact with that many people.
So you got to like choose who you can interact with and you can go back and
forth at some cunt face with the only reason why you're going back and forth.
He said something rude,
they said something rude to get you and Tyson.
There's plenty of people that won't do that.
So that's why blocking is awesome.
Just don't argue with them.
Just block it.
It's hard to do.
It's really easy to just fucking go.
Fuck you.
Block 10 people a day.
Black people.
Oh my God,
you didn't know that.
Oh that's you guys need,
you guys needed mentors tweeted out of by trolls right now
dickheads trolling eight easy Dick.
It's troll.
It ain't easy.
Oh,
that's funny.
It ain't easy.
Don't get me wrong.
I'm not saying the Trojans easing some trolling is kinda tricky.
You know,
there's a lot involved in that.
you gotta,
you gotta pretend you've got to get people mad,
you got to fit what's going to really get Ben fired up that he's gonna respond
and get really shitty with this.
Very difficult.
I'm very calm.
You say that he starts going after some,
you know,
finds out about some ex-girlfriend on Twitter and the attack,
the,
all they trying to do is just get you to respond.
So we tried to just try and get you to respond.
You love personal man.
They do need love.
They would way rather talk to you and be buddies most likely if you actually met
them,
but you know there's no fun in that.
We will be your friend.
Okay?
You start out there and making a mistake.
You're making it.
We will give you our credit card numbers.
Personally,
you should be friends with a lot of people that there's a lot of people out
there to be friends with,
but there's don't,
don't try to tame the cons.
I feel like we should
turn this podcast into a drinking game.
Every time you say con,
somebody has to drink black outcast.
He went a blackout counseling.
Someone wants a woke up for real.
Yeah.
It's a podcast I do where we drink a whole bottle Yeager meister and an hour.
That sounds awful,
but we have to finish it in one hour.
Can we,
can we make it like Wisconsin?
We're not doing that.
We're not going to kill honey.
Honey.
How dare you bro.
I love them.
I don't want it to be easy,
Brian.
We can't kill them.
Which you know,
listen,
Joe Rogan is the angel of death.
I'm just trying to hook you guys up and trying to keep you guys moving in any
way possible.
I want you guys to make more cds,
keep it coming.
Keep a calm.
Oh,
you don't have to be grateful.
Just keep doing what you're doing.
So that's the,
that's reward enough.
It's this amazing opportunity to be able to tell people about somebody.
I,
and I've never had a venue before,
but before this podcast there's no,
or before Twitter or any of this social media stuff,
there's no way.
You know,
even like something like you had to wait for an interview and go,
oh fuck this new bands.
Amazing.
You know,
by the time you do that,
you know,
the interview gets in a magazine.
It's months later now.
Just immediately.
We know it's tough because radio is a dying breed and we're not necessarily a
radio band.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean I guess we could be,
are you saying this
is radio?
Yeah,
this is,
this is the real radio.
This is,
I mean there's not a radio station except for like Sirius satellite radio that
gets as many listeners is this thing,
so that's amazing.
Yeah.
The weird,
the weird thing about the internet is that nobody even saw this coming,
you know,
they just,
somehow or another I will,
we're going to deal with and snap pictures.
I'll send you a picture,
whatever.
Nobody ever saw it.
Fucking file sharing and streaming shows and everything.
Free the,
what are they doing?
They're putting it out for free.
What the fuck and then this other model,
the radio model just kind of evaporates and there's no cds.
Cds.
That's like five more years.
That's insane.
I remember when I was a kid and they first came out with cds.
I'm like,
who the fuck is going to get those things?
Don't we already have cassette?
Has this tape is going?
No.
Why are you going to set a good enough?
That's kind of something I'm going to miss is I'm a,
I'm a sucker for mix tapes or mixed cds.
Oh my God,
I love it.
But someone can,
the playlist playlist is called easy.
Someone can put that in your watch.
USB Watches that are also MP three players.
Do you have Spotify?
Have you seen,
do you have Spotify or we're going to share with your phones?
I'm kind of Spotify illiterate.
Oh,
it's great.
It's pretty much like a mixed tape that you can have Joe's mix tape.
You can,
oh yeah.
You make your own like page,
right.
It's pretty much like a Facebook page for musics.
It's so you should because look,
balls of steel is the guy that hooked me up with you guys mean.
I mean it's clear that that's,
he's out there.
He's probably shooting whiskey right into his dick with a Turkey baster.
Harvey's on my message board.
He can be doing anything right for a bunch of savages.
Part blood seven told me about Spotify.
Thank you.
Thank you for our boats out.
We've had this podcast or this message board I started in 1998 and it just sort
of took on a life of its own.
Now it's got like millions of posts,
like six over 6 million posts and it's just the craziest,
most interesting group of Weirdos mixed with [inaudible].
A lot of farm.
It's basically I'm farming,
you know,
I'm allowing them,
I even keep some of them around.
I have it set up so that when they're assholes or if they're rude or something
like that,
that gets sent to special ed and then they get us,
they get a pink name by keeping them around.
Just making them even come to your right.
Please.
May I?
No,
I need to get some ice,
but I figured out today,
are you serious?
You just really asked to get up.
You should have raised your hand,
dude.
Why didn't you raise your fucking hand then?
We're going to,
we're going to have to become best friends to this.
This is weird bed getting hammered in front of each other and you're like,
may I please have some ice?
It's very respectful.
He's from,
he's from the Midwest.
Boy.
You're in New York,
Boston guy.
What?
I'm a that's,
that's sort of me too,
man.
I was born in New Jersey and I grew up mostly in Boston where my grandma lived
in Toms River.
When you think about,
oh,
Tom's river,
that's where the former UFC lightweight champion Frankie Edgar's from haulage
boy.
Shout out to Frankie.
I love that dude.
He just lost his title.
Unfortunately.
It's very,
very close decision and wants a rematch.
I support you Frankie Edgar in your bid for a rematch.
Good luck to you sir.
It's good man.
Frankie Edgar,
he's a beast.
I looked at shrimp out.
Who taught you?
Who taught you to do that?
From Wendy Wang.
Lady,
she beat the shit out of me.
Oh,
that's cool.
Yeah,
but I got that because I went and took one class with the Gracies.
Uh,
for people don't know what it is.
It's a form of HIPAA escaping.
Where are you?
You kind of get like a shrimp.
You get on your side and you kind of like Ben and kick like a shrimp and the
idea is to get out of a bad position.
So that's what,
so I'm with that.
So you learned it from a woman.
She brought me to this Brazilian Jujitsu class and I'm shrimping all over the
fucking place.
That's awesome.
Did you like,
yeah,
but I did.
I did.
Dude,
I'll get you free lessons.
You want to train with my best friends,
one of the best Jujitsu instructors in the world.
If you want,
you guys ran.
Oh Dude,
you're in,
you're in.
You're in a totally hook you guys up.
It's done.
Done deal.
Just doesn't cut it anymore.
No,
it doesn't.
You could learn some nasty guard techniques.
See the thing about your legs is a woman,
you know physically is not going to be as strong as a man.
It's just no way.
It especially a big man,
but your legs are strong as fuck.
Your legs are carrying you around all day and you're running.
I mean,
think about that.
What you knew you could walk for hours,
you know,
try walking on your fucking hands for hours.
So it was a woman's legs are incredibly strong.
And if a woman learns Jujitsu,
I have friends like my friend Felicia.
Okay?
She's a woman,
she's a Brazilian Jiu Jitsu black belt and she's only about 130 pounds and she's
ridiculously technical.
Like,
you know,
I'm,
I'm a,
a much bigger than her and I have a really hard time,
like just containing her and holding onto her.
She's just,
her technique is that good because not all of it.
She does everything.
She's a black belt.
She's super rare.
No.
So there was a,
there was a show,
I remember a guy named Seymour Butts who was like a porn star that had like a
reality show on showtime where it was like,
you know,
his,
like it was a reality show about his life,
like co producing porn films and you know,
living his life and you know,
dating,
oh it was a real weird show.
But one of the things he wanted to do was he wanted to start taking Brazilian
jujitsu lessons and have him roll with a girl.
Like they thought that would be funny to have him run with a girl.
But I don't think he expected Felicia to fucking strangle him because when they,
when they started rolling,
she fucking man handled him.
I mean,
she's a little girl.
She's five foot five maybe,
you know,
maybe 130 pounds maybe.
And she's fucking shrine.
Lily's dude take it as ours is about to break of an arm bar and him and triangle
in them.
It was fucking chaos.
It was like over and over and over again.
She's just tapping him.
I mean,
when you're talking about the size of the dog in the fight here,
is it mainly about her and leverage?
It's all about,
no,
she's not.
I mean she's a strong woman,
but she's a woman.
I mean it's not,
I mean you don't need to be that song if you have your shit together.
It's tech.
It's about her technique or technique is just that it's such a high level and
our defenses as such a high level and she just,
she knows exactly what she's doing so she doesn't have to exert nearly as much
force cause she's always in the right position and you know,
and she just like just technique.
It was wild to watch because I'd never seen like a man with no training go with
a woman who was a black belt.
So it was really intriguing.
It was funny,
she just ran right through crazy.
Like nothing.
Like she wasn't even tired.
That's like our friend Wendy.
She,
I mean,
not a black belt,
but she's
been doing it for a couple of years and she beat the shit out of me.
It's fun.
Yeah.
Is she tried to beat the shit out of banking.
I should totally do it.
She'd have honey honey death matches at the end of your show.
Oh my God.
We thought about,
we're working to,
Ben's like,
what the fuck are we talk about training
corporate,
other,
you know,
various
[inaudible] crafts and the carnival acts and violence.
We were crafts.
We're starting,
we're starting with a basketball tournament that we actually see truth.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Oh,
basketball tournament for like charity or something.
Yeah.
And it's going to be,
it's going to involve a show,
but like basically three on three,
like 10 minute games.
All these other indie rock hose.
Yeah.
Los Angeles is just don't have anything to do with that,
um,
organization that introduce you guys in Santa Monica.
There was no,
no,
no
that,
that's a different thing,
but we're just,
we're trying to be as involved as possible in all these nonprofit things.
I'm like,
arts education is kind of,
are the,
yeah,
we're trying to get,
explain,
explain what that was because I thought that was really interesting.
Well when we booked the show,
uh,
a friend of mine who was booking the venue every Monday night,
they would do a nonprofit that feature different nonprofit and the proceeds from
the night would go to that nonprofit.
And he allowed us to choose.
And there's a group called Coachart,
which is a arts education funding.
You know,
cause there's all these public schools that have literally no access to arts
education.
So you know,
I think there was drinks that night that uh,
went to at the door,
money went to uh,
this group.
Coachart.
Um,
and what we're,
what we're working on slowly is having this basketball tournament with us and a
bunch of,
you know,
other Los Angeles bans.
Cause I just want to play basketball.
We just want to just love basketball.
I've looked past William,
do you wish you were a big black guy?
Oh,
I wish I was in there.
If you were,
if you were a,
a big,
tall guy,
do you think that you'd be playing professional basketball or adapting to it?
I think if I,
yeah,
I think if I just took a different path with this body,
I go with the MBA.
Really good.
Yeah,
because I think it'd be excited for people to watch this with a wave of your
hand.
This his body.
Yeah,
exactly.
You should have just a what's up,
you know,
about a year ago,
Ben,
right?
Ben In all earnestness said to me,
he said,
he knows,
he's got to think,
I got this great idea for a reality show and it's basically going to be me for
an entire year training for the NBA
because I could do it.
Who wouldn't?
Who wouldn't watch that.
There's someone that looks like me could get into law.
I'll tell you what,
for real,
for real.
If you got,
how old are you?
I'm 26 it might be too late.
Not too late,
not too late.
It off.
My knees are gone.
No,
no,
no.
You say that they've got all kinds of new things they're doing now.
What?
What does it on cartilage?
What does it,
you know they're doing.
They're taking your blood and they're putting it some sort of a centrifuge and
then they take it out and shoot the fucking platelets right into your knee with
human growth hormone.
Really?
Shit.
Some stem regenerate tissue.
Yeah.
There's a lot of that going on.
Hang in there fella.
I'm thinking about freezing my semen to,
yeah,
I've done.
Okay,
let's not,
let's not do that,
but I don't think so.
Let's take fish oil.
You taken fish oil.
None.
You've got to take fish.
Oil is very important for joints.
Anytime you have sore joints.
Amazing.
Not just that.
It's good for mental property.
Is that your spot?
That's my phone.
I shouldn't have left it on.
That's not cool.
Come on.
We're drinking.
Phil Collins.
Interesting
to imagine what you're talking about it,
but
he's a vice cop.
Once you guys become famous,
once you guys become huge,
which you will to inevitable.
I'm,
I'm happy I'm at you now and you still talk to me.
But once you guys become famous,
then you on a reality show when you want to try to enter into the NBA,
that would be fucking awesome.
And then bouncing it in with your schedule of touring.
I want to be the executive producer.
Excellent.
We're actually looking for funding.
Um,
if you're interested,
obviously my mid range game is pretty good,
but I think I need to be on the arc is really what I need to develop with my
son.
How are you with battle rapping,
rapping and you battle rap cause that might come up.
You're a musician,
you know,
this is pretty good.
I mean,
I don't want any battle.
We'll see.
I mean,
you can battle rap.
I know I could get to a place where I'd be confident.
Yes.
I would say that if you,
if you're a young white boy like yourself and you're really good at basketball,
some shits come up.
Okay,
something's come up.
There's been some situations where you had to establish a position and the
let's,
I mean I'm not,
Suzanne is very kind of,
I don't want to create a false image of myself in terms of how good I am at
basketball,
but I will accept any challenges.
But you know,
little rec center for Christmas and we meet those 14 year old.
It was fucking awesome.
But we also did lose to support
and the rest of the band,
I wasn't
a few,
always been a big basketball fan,
could rebound like diaries.
What do you think about the color green tire?
No,
for real.
I just love the game.
I mean I used to play a lot of soccer,
but basketball,
I don't know,
I like it better.
It's,
it's so fast paced and it's like,
uh,
it's so much improvisation.
You know what I mean?
At least in his pickup basketball,
when he started talking about basketball,
he started going black.
Did you feel that he went a little hook on it?
We know,
you know,
we'll talk about that.
It's all about improvisation.
I'm sorry.
I'm just kidding.
Bad.
There's a fine line between rock and roll and being a professional athlete.
Hmm.
I'll support that.
I think it's a big fat stupid lines.
There's a lot of difference there.
Actually,
I'm working on getting us littered with heroin needles before
they'll be dope.
Doing some warm ups.
Just like some seventies gangsters from New York.
It's fun times.
Jogging suits they're in.
They're in the mail.
Have you?
Yeah,
it's gross.
We're drinking this weird rum stuff.
Have you ever had interest in the music?
Um,
you know,
I,
yes.
I actually moved to La for acting and really,
really well for a little while.
Thank God you go here for that.
He abandoned that shit.
Right?
Did you,
it's way too cool to be an actress because you're willing to call.
Um,
no.
I worked for a number of years and,
and I just,
when I moved out to La,
I,
uh,
I went through my first breakup.
Wow.
Yeah,
please tell us more.
It was very dark times.
Oh No.
Does that inspire a good music pack down a few lbs.
I got really sad and I was so,
I wrote a lot of pathetic sad songs.
Yeah.
It was like really shit.
You're right when your heart's broken.
But you know what?
It was really funny because it was just like a crazy chain of events where like
I played a couple open mics because my roommate was a booker at the time and I
didn't know anybody.
I met my roommate on craigslist.
How long ago?
We're talking about,
I was 18 1927 oh nine years ago.
It's been seven years ago.
He's still fucking wait,
I'm in my late twenties and Ben is 26 and he is in his mid twenties or young
buck.
Yeah.
Wow.
Well it's all about,
what are you saying?
It's all about positivity,
y'all
devotee.
So,
so we,
you just started going up on open mic nights
just fucking around.
Well,
you know,
it was crazy.
Like my first show,
I met all these people that I'm still friends with today and every time it just
like snowballed.
And then I met Ben like maybe a couple months later and we started writing
together and it really happened.
Like we started putting some songs on my space.
That's what I'm saying.
Thought about maybe you guys being the captain and Tennille Park too.
Oh,
I love that song.
Never thought of it.
Keep us together.
They're not bad man.
That's bad.
You're going to be good today.
I like know it's been awesome.
So you guys immediately hit it off.
You meet.
What?
What's your impressions of Each Other?
I mean,
I always wondered how bands that work.
Work.
We hit it off as friends and I was,
I was pretty green,
you know,
like I,
I've always sang and I played the violin since I was a kid and,
um,
but I,
and I played a little guitar,
but Ben had been,
Ben had already written an entire record,
recorded it.
And um,
you know,
he,
he kind of showed me the way the ropes,
if you will.
Ben,
what is it like for you man?
You're a musician.
You meet this chick,
she can sing her ass off.
And w w what do you,
how you,
uh,
how did,
how does it become a band
man?
I feel like the band stuff just happened.
I,
you know,
we kinda got outside forces,
like this situation outside forces just come around every once in a while.
I was compelled,
pushed us,
pushed us along honestly.
But the w you know,
when we play at first we were playing some songs that I'd written and Suzanne
just sang them better than anybody else.
[inaudible] so it was,
uh,
I dunno,
it's Kinda like a no brainer.
I guess it was just like,
okay,
this is girl can sing.
And then we started writing together and we just had a great relationship.
Did you have day jobs at the time?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I sold barbecue.
Barbecue.
Yeah.
Those are,
those are my people.
Oh,
that's a good place.
It's fantastic.
But I eman was only like 10 widgets where I lost 15 pounds when I stop working
with.
Sure,
sure.
Did you ever go to doctor Hughley wireless part?
The lobbies in Van Eyes?
Ooh,
it's worth the drive.
It's tasty.
God Damn,
you gotta give yourself like a good like day to prepare and no food in the
morning.
Man.
Don't fuck with breakfast.
You got to go right there.
I go.
I,
I'd go there for like a 1:00 PM lunch breakfast sort of a thing.
It's ridiculous.
You ever go to DC?
Yeah.
Washington oohs and Aahs who's an absence.
That spot is the greatest.
I mean it's similar to baby blues.
This is soul food place.
So you were working baby blues.
Where were you working?
I wasn't working at the time.
I was just like,
I was lucky enough I had Suzanne.
Right.
Do you know if my money?
Yeah,
exactly.
So you weren't,
you were teaching?
I was teaching guitar.
Um,
and uh,
I,
I was really lucky to be great friends with the producer named Andy Paley and I
was working on all these cartoons.
I was like playing on this cartoon soundtracks.
I liked good food.
Yeah.
It's just like random.
Yeah,
it was hilarious.
So I got to do all these amazing TV projects,
stuff like that.
Um,
you know,
I guess that would,
and then so you guys form a song,
this is what I want to know.
Who's,
who's writing this stuff?
Are you guys writing it all together?
Well now we are,
our,
our first record was a lot,
half the record was Ben songs that he from his previous record that he recorded.
And um,
now are we,
we pretty much write everything together and um,
it's,
it's really interesting to like kind of just watch the whole thing developed
because it's,
you know,
we're,
we're getting better,
like our musicianship or writing or performing and it's like,
it's really cool to just keep striving for the next level.
And,
um,
we write all the time and sometimes we write for other people and it's,
it's become something that's really,
um,
you know,
I can humbly say like,
once you're secure with it,
it's so much fun.
Yeah.
You know,
because there,
there was a time when,
when I said,
you know,
like when I was younger,
19 and just getting started where I was so insecure about like,
oh my God,
is this sound like shit?
Is that stupid?
Is that Cliche,
you know,
and you just kind of trial and error.
I have to go with it.
And,
and now it's,
it's just like,
it's,
it's like kind of a whole nother entity.
It's like once you write a song,
you just kind of put it out there and it's really,
it's really fucking fun.
And the big reward is in the creativity,
right?
The big reward is in bringing something to life where it wasn't there,
that didn't exist and through you or collaboration or whatever it is,
boom.
All of a sudden there is,
well there you did awesome stories.
You know,
they're all our stories.
And that's what I think the best part is that they're,
they're true.
You know,
it's,
it's not like I feel like I'm playing some,
I'm acting,
you know,
and that,
and that's what's,
that's a nice part about playing music as opposed to when I was an actress,
is that like,
this is mine in hours.
Well,
there's a deadness to something.
Like there's beautiful
songs that other people have written and then people will,
will sing them and it's,
it's beautiful.
But there's a difference.
There's a big difference between someone who wrote the song and is singing the
song and someone who is seeing the song that somebody just sold them or
somebody's,
you know,
got them to sing.
There's a,
there's a difference is a disconnect.
There's something that happens in any form of art,
whether it's great acting or great singing,
songwriting or,
or great literature.
Like what there's,
there's,
when someone fucking just nails it and when they nail it,
they're completely tuned into it.
You know what I'm saying?
I mean,
it's not just,
I'm going to sing this song with this weird gay guy wrote.
He's really good at it.
You know,
he sells them,
but they go and they,
they make it,
cause he's always a cool gay guys,
like on top of Shit.
Those lot of those songwriter guys.
But you know,
you know what I mean?
I mean there's like a disconnect.
There's a disconnect between the work and even if you feel it,
even if it's beautiful,
you know,
there's,
it's not quite the same.
But I do think there's something appealing about having just a song that's good
enough that it can be universally applicable.
You know what I mean?
And then,
and then someone who has a beautiful instrument and a beautiful expression.
I completely agree.
I know what you're saying.
I,
I think both,
you know what I'm saying?
I think the tributes and covers are,
or do you know that little kid,
you remember that little kid?
There was a video and he got on Ellen and he was,
uh,
he was singing uh,
um,
a lady Gaga Song.
What's the kids name?
Song.
And I know we've talked about it so many times.
I know.
Do you know the kid I'm talking about?
Either way please.
You gotta pee.
I gotta get some more
questions.
He's singing that Papa Razzi song and it's a cover,
but it's,
you know,
it's an 11 year old kid and it's fucking brilliant.
It's really brilliant.
And in that case,
yeah,
he's tapping in.
Even if he's not,
he didn't write the song again.
It's like you believe it.
If it's true to somebody cause I have,
I think some songs that Ben wrote and if they don't,
if I,
if it doesn't resonate with me in a,
in a place that I can,
well I think this kid who was singing this song clearly was not believing the
lyrics,
but what these lyrics represented to him was real like personal emotional
feelings because it's not what he knows about smoking cigarettes and the
Paparazzi and all this nonsense.
He's not resonating with the actual song.
Maybe he's connecting to the idea of this woman,
Lady Gaga who's going through this and he's channeling himself through her,
but most likely he's just trying to show how emotional and conflicted he is in
his,
his expression and it just so powerful that you,
you know,
it,
it vibes with the actual song that makes no sense coming from an 11 year old
boy.
But when,
I love that that that kid did that,
but if he was 40 I wouldn't like it as much as look creepy.
Where's your own shit to capitalize on the now
not what I'm saying.
You're already peaking kid.
No,
that's going to suck.
When you write your own shit and you,
you sing your own shit.
To me it's,
it's,
I feel like more connected to it,
you know.
I'll second that.
That's why you guys are bad ass man.
I totally both.
Brian doesn't even like her music with words.
All Brian likes is like,
oh Whoa,
whoa,
wait,
got a house music band music.
I think I like all the eight bit.
Sounds a that's cool.
Once in a while.
Are you a jam band Kinda Guy?
I grew up hippie.
We more by you nailed him.
He's good.
Piss up a rope.
Yeah.
It's like what is that the greatest songs ever.
Do you know about the Wean doing the pizza hut commercial?
Hold up just saying piss up a rope and one of the what song called Piss up a
rope by Wayne.
We did a whole hour songs ever.
It,
we did a whole album where it's like old school country sounds so,
so the best thing about Wayne is like every single one of their songs sounds
like a different band.
Hold on,
shut up.
I never heard this piss up a rope.
Wean lets you play their shit on the Internet.
That's one of the coolest things about all right.
I hope so.
No they do.
That's their,
they're really like open about like you playing shit on the Internet and the use
of Shit.
I love that.
You know,
a certain point in time people have to realize that there's no way you're going
to ever control how many people are downloading your shits and possible.
But you can control what you do and if you could buy it and then people buy it,
borrow while she watches.
Do you ever wonder what it's like to be me?
No smokes
and salts folks breaking my back.
You in the best that I came,
Scott Board.
So in the fucking room,
his,
oh wait,
I got to tell you about the
pizza hut story because they were commissioned to write a song for Pizza Hut and
it was like Wayne was.
Wayne was and they apparently,
and God if I say this incorrectly,
I apologize,
but they basically,
they,
they wrote this tune and the Ab is on Youtube.
So you could find this if you want it to,
but basically they wrote this too and it was like where the cheese go
kill zone kind of like fold up beside,
it's supposed to be like,
so they write and then they wrote this brilliant song,
right?
It's like witty and they produce it and it sounds great.
It's all about this like fold over Stromboli cal zone type thing.
It's like where the cheese go,
where the cheese go and pizza hut was like,
Hey,
can you make it a little more ridiculous?
And so they,
they,
you know,
basically they insulted the band and the band came back with the same song every
verbatim except for where the motherfucking cheese.
So great.
It's so,
it's so brilliant.
Obviously it was never placed here.
It is on a commercial.
That's hilarious.
Oh you've got
it.
Oh that's hilarious.
[inaudible]
that's so ridiculous.
Oh my God.
That's one of the most ridiculous things I've ever seen.
Great.
They used to be my ringtone back in the day.
Oh Brian's.
You always get the most past your shit.
If you ever looking for something bizarre.
If you hear a rumor,
a whiff of something in the air,
so it's true contact Brian.
Brian's got the inside word on all nerd shit.
He'll,
he'll let you know immediately.
What the fuck is up?
Cheese go.
I Dunno.
Yeah,
I love,
I love bands that do that.
Put all their shit out there.
I like the Radiohead sells all their shit online.
I think that's a future,
right?
Yeah.
It's a matter of time.
We talked about all the time like this,
this,
uh,
an APP stitcher that were available on you.
Get your car now.
Oh,
someone's phone's still sing gay songs.
I'm like,
God,
this time.
What is this?
Can we hear that ringtone?
What is that little bow with the two different ones for different people call
you.
You only have one ring tone.
Oh,
our manager,
your manager talking about the Christmas song on Spotify.
It's way past Christmas.
Yeah.
What's your
drop that guy [inaudible] joking.
Rough.
Listen,
there's a lot of things I say when people think I'm really being serious.
He's,
there's an instant that you have when you're a comedian to say the worst shit
possible all the time and you try to fight it as much as possible.
When when someone fucks up your like firearm,
firearm,
I don't really mean that dude,
totally don't mean that,
but tell him to relax,
but the fucking Christmas Song,
Jesus Christ,
just get the word out there about problems in the future with him.
Joke,
may we contact you for it all costs from me directly.
I'll take care of it.
She,
you know,
no one can ever tell you what to do.
If they do,
it won't work.
You know the only thing you can do that's good is put yourself out there,
put your music out there and keep going.
All that other stuff.
Let them deal with it.
Publicity stuff and nonsense,
but dominant.
Have to tell you what to do.
You know that's the bottom line.
There's a lot of prognosticators from the outside and they'll sit back and they
go,
what you need to do is,
have you ever think
you might be holding it back
is ever anyone ever say that?
Ben,
if he just a lot of crap about his hair.
Cut your hair,
but the ladies was talking about the ladies,
then you were a talented artist.
It would be a shame if you got as far as you got and then suddenly it all falls
apart because if you look
just like that,
I'm not saying interesting to set Jewish.
No,
but Suzanne,
she is right now did for my love of Jewish people.
I must immediately change my accent.
I appreciate that.
Yes.
I got this wired back,
man.
I got this game.
I know the game was vaguely African
hair.
We're going to cut your hand night five years from now.
You'll do whatever the fuck you want,
man.
What y'all call him?
This is what you want,
right?
Lifts.
Everyone wears lifts.
Yeah,
come on back.
I got up,
I got him.
I got the socks stuffed in my pants and everything.
Ain't no preaching.
Have you have,
has anyone ever given you any anal bleachings are good.
Move to don.
Hey.
Oh No.
Oh no kidding.
By the,
by the,
by so kidding.
The blacker the berry,
the sweeter the juice.
Ladies and gentlemen,
how dare you make me go there.
Don't challenge me.
I don't remember what we're even talking about now at this one or reason out of
your asshole.
That's not what we're talking about.
I remember that.
It's sailor Jerry.
It's his right.
Oh yeah.
I just feel like Jerry,
has anybody ever given you any preposterous advice as far as look or image or
yes.
Please tell me.
Suzanne,
what have they done to you?
Those fucks motivators.
I'm not gonna.
I'm not gonna name names.
Don't,
don't do it.
You don't have to do that.
Told once to,
um,
well,
you know what?
No,
I can't go for and then it's too late now.
It's too late.
I got your back.
She was like,
funny.
So like basically,
you know,
like I ever mentioned
earlier that like,
you know,
our band,
we're at this level where we write together and we,
we do like your rain making arrangements with music and it's,
it's really fulfilling and rewarding and,
and we're watching it do all these cool things.
I'm like,
be on your show.
Holy Shit.
Balls.
Oh.
But I was told a few years back to when I was just starting out and trying to
figure out how to do things that,
um,
I should work on being attractive and funny and a good performer and,
and not write songs and let my band mate write the songs and wow.
And I was like,
you,
you want me to do what?
It's like,
oh,
well this,
the guy was trying to fucking not,
and I hope to God not because
I just threw a lot of women.
Don't realize how many guys were interacting with them on a fucking,
no,
I just wanted to control thing.
I'm gonna Hook you up.
I'm gonna help you out here.
Yeah.
What do you got?
Oh,
he's,
he's way older than 50
probably.
Yeah.
15 in your eyes,
in your eyes.
He's out of the game and his eyes.
He's a polite.
Yeah.
Oh Gosh.
Yes.
And,
and he knows,
he knows he can't fuck you.
He knows he can't fuck you.
He knows you're not attracted to him.
But his instincts will always be to be little and to try to in some way to find
something wrong with you instead of like the answer representation or
a representative rather have an artist like the way you should be looking at it.
And it's like trying somehow or another to to be an aid to build them up.
Not to like shoot them down and correct this or change that,
but to just pump up all the good stuff.
Like you know,
like,
like look at them as you know,
like you're in some sort of a partnership with them and the more you can rise
them up,
the better it would be for everybody.
So it should all be positive and I'll be like reinforcing it and honest and
everything but,
but still positive.
So when a guy,
he's a representative kind of like shits,
I knew a little bit like that and tries to change what he's selling and change
who you are.
I always think he wants to fuck.
Yeah,
but you know,
what will the power thing regardless,
regardless if that is true or not.
Listen to me.
Stop it.
Stop with the modesty.
Don't even talk right now.
I'm serious.
Listen,
you are very pretty girl.
Very.
You're very pretty girl.
You know that.
You know the end.
You also talented.
So for anybody gets in a position where they're selling something,
most of them are fucks.
Most of them,
like there's a lot of good,
great agents and great,
great managers and great representatives of artists.
I love my manager to death.
I've had the same manager since I was an open mic comedian.
I love him to death.
We also love you,
Jeffrey.
Sorry about the [inaudible] name is Jeffrey too.
Oh my God,
that's crazy.
Oh,
his name is Jeff Susman.
My manager's name.
No bullshit.
What?
That's not our it guy's last name.
But go on the bottom line is,
bottom line is,
I'm trying to tell you,
this guy was trying to fuck you.
Well,
we're trying to help you out,
but I think it was more powerful.
I think it was the power for,
I think you're right.
It's not just that it's be,
it's because he's beyond the possibility of being sexually attractive to you as
well.
So because of that it's gotta be the power.
Fuck.
I would really would like the regular thought process makes me really
uncomfortable because I know is that disturbing.
But I will tell you this,
that that those things like when you know I was like 22 and I needed a change.
You know,
you need champions when you're just getting started and you're kind of like
hoping that you do a good job and then of course a person that you're looking up
to.
You said some bullshit like that to you.
Yes.
I think that in the,
in the long run those things are a good thing because you can't,
you get over it and then you get better,
you know,
and,
and those things just kind of bounce right off
you.
Listen,
there's nothing wrong with who you are ever.
So if,
if you're,
if you're a person and you like this,
you like country music,
you like dressing like this,
whatever the fuck you like,
whatever,
whatever your trying to suck in your jeans,
whatever it is.
That should be what you gravitate towards one time.
And as soon as someone comes along and is like,
listen dude,
you know,
you're,
you're going to have to like change this and change that.
And,
and when,
whenever someone tries to deviate you off of who you are naturally instead of
just trying to enhance you,
they're not doing it.
They're not helping you out,
man.
No,
but I think that's the general attitude and approach in the show business and
maybe our businesses,
I don't know how to justify their mean is they want to add some ingredients to
the soup.
Yeah.
Oh Man.
That fucking kid could get nowhere.
You're this mustache train the fucking beer thing going on.
You don't make my beard.
I love it.
Don't get me wrong in Madison time.
Sometimes
you have to take that hit and,
and know that you're smarter than that person and,
and keep going,
you know,
and,
and use them.
Or someone
could actually give you good advice.
That's the truth.
That's the craziest thing.
So we could actually give you the,
you know,
it's rare,
but then again,
they shouldn't be,
it shouldn't be douchey about it.
Yeah.
Idiots.
But,
but the idea that men and men always want women to dress like a certain life.
Maybe if you dressed a little bit sexier,
can you be more of a C Cup?
That's impossible.
We need bigger Erin Areola is,
can you get a tattoo around your area that looks like a regular guy?
I had a nickel for every time.
Okay.
I worked with this check for a cold check,
but I won't say her name out of respect because I don't know if she wants people
to know about this,
but she had cutlass these,
these rubber cutlets in your Bra.
They're like,
they're like a temporary fake boob.
They,
they look like chicken.
A big slab of a rubber chicken and you stuff your tests with them.
It's used to be at somewhere on another,
like it's acceptable.
Whereas like tissue papers,
ridiculous.
But he's a cop had to wear four.
Yeah.
I mean I used to,
I used to do some modeling back in the day.
Oh Shit.
What's up?
Well,
it was like,
it was just catalogs or basketball.
Ramzan the old bag over there.
Somebody did some modeling.
Now we understand why you had the shady manager.
I understand you were in transition.
No big deal.
Listen,
I was a paper boy when I was young.
It's cool.
Great choice for this.
That's not true.
Dare you.
How dare you play stupid.
Um,
zoo lander.
We're playing south by southwest and um,
we're apparently because you know when,
when you,
when you play certain shows,
they give you things like clothes or fry boots and we,
we got offered this position where they're like,
Hey,
will you guys play this show?
We'll give you free clothes,
but you have to rock walk on a runway.
And I mean,
this was a case.
I really just,
I,
I'm,
you know,
that's,
you just kind of walked by and be like,
hey,
check out this fucking Jean jacket right now.
But I'm more excited for Ben to do it because I think that like from a zoo
lander standpoint,
it's just going to be
really truly Danny's drop.
We'll be updating your Facebook profile period,
blood
model.
I want to see runway model.
I've done it.
I know I'm not gonna lie
together.
And the photographer said to Ben,
you have the most beautiful Jesus' eyes I've ever seen.
And she just referred to him for the rest of the day.
Is Jesus' eyes taken out?
Ladies?
What'd that feel like?
Did you feel like a lot of weight was on your shoulders?
Just a lot of responsibility.
Humankind was that,
but I was carrying someone and the only
two footprints in the sand,
could you imagine if I pulled her aside
and that was going to say,
could you imagine if you pulled her aside and say,
listen,
I want you to keep a secret.
I can't do that.
I'm not comfortable with that.
Jesus.
I am the Lord and I'm back.
I am not humorless.
I'm not humorous.
I am a man and I also am the Holy Spirit.
Let's do modeling.
Tell no one.
I gotta walk the Walk My,
they're called [inaudible] about to call me.
Give you those chicken cutlets.
It wouldn't be that hard,
man.
You know what you would do.
You would,
you know,
even if you thought that it was hard to pitch,
say,
listen,
I'm not Jesus,
but I'm the new guy.
His name is Ben.
It's the new Messiah.
Jesus.
Before there was a cheeses,
I mean,
nobody knew what the fuck are you,
you know,
you couldn't say before Jesus's birth,
you can't,
couldn't say praise Jesus.
People go,
what the fuck are you talking about?
You know,
why could,
Jesus didn't exist yet,
but Ben's,
he like praise heroines here.
It's Ben now Ben,
and that will be the new thing.
It'd be a praise band.
There's a lot of bands out there,
Joe.
There's a lot of bands,
but not,
there's a lot of,
hey,
Suze is out there too,
but they escaped by this.
She,
man,
you got to tell you have pitched it.
You got to start your own call.
Do you have any land anywhere in the middle of nowhere?
I don't,
but what I'm looking for a plot.
Listen,
how much beard can you actually grow?
Can we be real?
Are you trimming that?
This is kind of all I got to be a little catchy.
Yes.
Good call.
What I would like would,
I would like if you comfortable,
it's just something that looks like a little unkempt.
Something that goes over the lips.
Yeah.
In the mouth where you really don't have an ego.
You know the shower for a couple of days,
you know you want to be hygienic,
but you want,
you want to not give a fuck.
Okay.
We don't want to stink positive.
You don't want to turn into a negative,
but uh,
you know,
I don't give a fuck.
Might be a positive.
That's all I'm saying.
Okay.
I will follow this path.
Imagine if you were like an agent for cult members.
Refer for cult leaders.
Like,
listen,
I think we're about about to get,
get busy with this cult,
but what I need from you is more beard.
Got To work on our image.
You got to work at,
I mean,
really we're lucky that show Biz people don't get involved in colt making
because of cult man.
He really was like,
fuck yeah.
Could you imagine if Alec Baldwin wanted to start his own cult?
They'd be a lot of menopausal women.
There's the lining in the Alec Baldwin cult,
right.
Just a woman who wants him to yell at her and then hug or just some,
some weird situation because
it is very difficult sometimes
while I'm drunk.
Yeah.
I'm getting there a little bit.
This is pretty quick.
My face is so red right now.
There's like some sort of heat or Roy bailed and left us with,
this is the first show I've done since I shaved my head
here.
They wanted me to ask you why you shaved your head.
Is it done?
Yeah,
it seems like,
it seems like there's no video.
I've gotten several.
Well the audio seems to be going though.
Let me see if the audience gone.
Hurricane is Yadi Rolling.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Um,
but the walls are purple.
Yeah.
I don't know what the fuck happened.
Let me call Brian Real quick.
Suzanne is wearing a lacy type shirt.
Joe Shaved his head.
I'm holding a terra Patrick book.
I could read a random paragraph from it if you'd like.
Our first stop was a sleazy lingerie store in Hollywood.
Well,
you read and Tera Patrick's biography.
Why do I have my pants on the point?
Let's,
let's go back to one.
Let me call Brian and make sure that this is all really going down because I
feel it's up.
Jeff,
it says of all the people online,
if you're,
if you're watching online,
it says that it's on,
but it doesn't seem to be on.
Okay.
So we'll call them dry right now.
I'll continue to read.
So what did someone have a question?
What was the question?
Somebody asked me.
They said ask Joe why he shaved his head.
I tapped out,
tapped out to hair loss tabs.
There's a certain point in time
I didn't even tap out,
but I do a whole bit about America.
I cheated before tapped out.
Where did he go?
My fucking freak employee has vanished.
Hey Brian is the feeds down man,
people are complaining crazy.
There's nothing on c c u stream black.
Oh,
oh boy.
Anyway,
um,
my hair was gross.
Got Tired of dealing with it so I shaved it.
Yeah,
Go pee now cause I got to go to,
I've been thinking about it.
Me and Betty going to get to know each other.
I don't wait.
Oh God,
yes.
I'm after you though.
So don't do you have a knife in your pocket?
I do.
Oh my God,
you got to give me an up top.
I like how you said her name on it.
I like how your rocket,
she gets up.
I'm like,
does that a fucking knife is a really bad eh?
I like it.
A of gate.
It did that last time Joe.
Like it just like in the middle of recording it just stopped.
Is it?
It doesn't read though,
right?
Yeah.
I have it saved on my desktop.
But it doesn't say on here.
Yeah,
I dunno what's so could we reboot it?
What do we got to do?
I think it's,
we're working right now,
but it doesn't seem to be working on this side Bro,
because I turned the volume on some,
it's not odd man.
Should I read more terror Patrick?
Yeah man.
Oh,
we're back.
It is back now.
Okay.
Tony.
Leah became my next thing.
You know,
when we have such a fabulous show,
we have so many people that are trying to watch it at the same time and
sometimes shit goes wrong.
Ladies and gentlemen,
that's not perfected.
It would always be,
it's always going to be on your Vimeo.
So anytime like this happens,
always just go to your website,
Joe rogan.net.
Yeah.
And folks,
you should also know that folks that are watching this,
um,
or rather listening to this,
if you ever wanted to watch,
especially the ones that we do at the ice house and it's really pretty bad ass.
We have a whole multi camera setup and there's a switcher and it's like a
halfassed cable access TV show,
but you can watch it.
You could watch it on Vimeo and people are actually watching.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
At least 2000 people right now are watching this too.
Right now it's 2082,
uh,
live bus a lot of people,
but that's a small amount.
Majority of
them or listening to it and it'd be three format.
The,
um,
the podcast,
the video podcast market is like a tiny fraction of what it is for the audio
podcast market.
People want to listen to the jam when their car in traffic,
you know,
couple of years though.
I think that will change.
Do you think so?
Because I think there's always going to be times where you're commuting and
that's why people love audio.
And that's where we come in and commuting.
We come in while people are driving,
like,
you know,
there's,
there's a,
there's sort of a,
um,
a place for all sorts of different types of entertainment.
You know,
you want undivided attention when you watch a movie,
but with a podcast,
we like travel with people were on planes with people right now.
Right now we're in cars with people,
you know,
we're,
we're hiking with people were at the gym with people,
you know,
it's,
it's a weird,
sort of a form of entertainment.
So it's,
uh,
you know,
so the visual aspect is this tiny fraction.
It's about 500,000 people in it was amazing.
Yeah.
Well,
it started out with just a laptop and like we had a Webcam.
We were just answering Twitter questions.
I don't know what happened,
but,
but now it's the most fun thing I've ever done.
And you know,
all the TV Shit I've ever done.
It's all fun.
But this is the only thing that you could do whatever you do,
anything.
You know,
we have you guys on.
Yeah,
come on.
We gotta play music.
Do you want to tune your shit?
I'm going to take a leak.
So talk amongst yourselves or Brian,
you got any questions for them or do you want it to him?
I'll be right back.
Ladies and gentlemen,
I'll talk to you while they pay,
but Brian,
tell them about your weekend.
So a,
Hey,
I,
if you guys,
uh,
we,
I just put up a new podcast today.
I knew Brian Cowen podcasts and we interviewed Jeremy Pivot and we went to his
house in Hollywood.
And it is a,
a video version is going to be up later tonight,
but the audio versions on iTunes right now.
So have you subscribed to death squad on iTunes?
You'll be able to download that and it was pretty cool.
Uh,
also if you live in the Los Angeles area this Friday,
uh,
Joe Rogan is going to be at the Ice House for the Ice House chronicles and
that's here at the Ice House Comedy Club in Pasadena,
California.
You can buy tickets at Ice House comedy Dotcom and uh,
it's going to be Joe Rogan and a bunch of other comics and we just pretty much,
um,
we all talk like in a green room style here and we do it as a podcast at 9:00 PM
Pacific and then at 10 o'clock the show,
next door starts in one by one.
We go from the green room to the,
uh,
whatever.
What am I talking about?
I Dunno.
Jesus went into commercial mode.
No,
no,
we're,
we're totally,
yeah,
we're on.
It was always on it.
It just discussing how we're drunk right now.
Yeah.
Oh Shit.
Are there any requests we could just play?
Yeah.
Do you know any krabby patty songs?
Yes,
I do actually.
Okay,
great.
Cause I want to hear a crappy Chinese art,
but that's a real song.
Do you know that?
Krabby Patty.
Oh yeah.
Yeah,
that's,
I was on that.
Oh,
really?
Yeah.
Oh,
cool.
Oh wait,
that's the book was fun.
Yeah.
That's cool.
Brian Wilson was always on that.
You know about sponge Bob.
Do you have kids?
I know I smoke a lot of wheat.
Oh.
And he's gonna look,
Andy Paley come on the best day ever.
A friend who wrote all the spongebob songs,
Andy Paley.
Um,
we went to his wedding a few years back in Kansas where he got married in Kansas
and at his wedding he,
we perform some spongebob songs.
Oh,
that's awesome.
It was a blast.
Tom Kenny,
the guy who does the voice of Spongebob was right there and perform.
Can you stand up comic?
Yeah.
He's the voice of Spongebob.
Oh,
you're rolling?
Yeah.
Do you guys watch adventure time?
Awesome.
Have you ever heard,
seen him?
You will love adventure time.
Okay.
It's on the cartoon network.
You guys get on iTunes.
It's adventure times by Penelton ward in it's,
it's crack.
You will watch a million.
They talk about DMT.
They've,
it's just like an adult cartoon for kids.
It's great.
I don't understand.
Hey Brian,
do you want me to adjust any of these microphones via,
no,
that's good cause I was just going to do one of these.
Yeah,
that's fine.
I just want to point out that you guys were the first band that we've ever had
perform all those podcasts.
Honor.
Oh please.
It's an honor for us.
This is solving,
so if you have any other bands on the show,
can we put them through some sort of level of hazing?
Yes,
because that would be really fun.
You can be on the board whenever you want.
The only one who has a grandfather clause though was Everlast because he already
talked about it.
He wants to come on and do it.
Okay,
fair enough.
Fair enough.
We don't want to fuck with that guy and he's a great guy.
I let it slide last shout and shout out the dead mouse.
Do you want to shout out to be real to maybe real after we did the last podcast,
be real.
Wants to do a bunch of them.
We're going to do a back and forth.
Right?
We're going to do them with their studio and simulcasts his,
his,
his dream.
My use trim.
Same time.
Right.
We're gonna do all that.
So we're going to,
we're going to do that real soon.
Maybe I could just have a tiny fucked yes son.
Oh,
I'm driving back to,
that's cool.
I know.
I'm a very capable drivers.
Jesus Christ.
Is this going to be filmed or something?
Does this mean I can't run for public office?
No,
it's,
it's just online right now.
Don't worry about it.
That's the shit that gave Neil Armstrong when they made them fake the moon
landings.
What?
I'm
[inaudible]
please do.
All right.
What are you guys gonna Sing?
We're going sing a tune called back to you that we have not yet recorded play.
Right.
That's how you're going to play in after you've not yet recorded back to you.
There's a new song we never know.
No,
it's been around for a while.
We just never recorded it.
Okay.
Paul.
My head.
Yay.
When it's coming back,
the
baby
to smile to see.
Hang in on this.
Wow.
It's coming back to you,
Shane.
You Sway Donna's saying,
oh no,
I know.
Up goes around,
comes back,
goes back around your birthday.
Sound like dirt to me.
Swept up.
Nicky's hot.
Agree.
Now
coming back.
Yeah.
Thank God you didn't make it as an actress.
Oh,
I have to say thank God that didn't work out.
Thank
you Jesus.
So important sometimes for shit to go wrong.
So,
so important sometimes for shit to go wrong.
Come on man.
That was beautiful.
It was amazing.
God Damn,
that was awesome.
Thank you.
You guys are a fucking potent combination man.
I've heard that song.
That song has never been released.
It's not an anything.
Is it online anywhere?
I it.
Well there's that.
There's that,
um,
that as quarter house video.
That's what we haven't done.
Like an audio recording of it yet.
No.
Bleeds it in that show that you came,
but I heard it before that it must be the Esquire house thing because there's
two songs on the Esquire house thing.
Right?
That's the angel of death in that one.
Yeah.
The Angel of death was the one who want to hear that one as well.
Oh,
definitely.
We'll play that for you later,
later,
later.
Make me wait for it.
Not,
may I go to the bathroom please.
Oh please.
Oh,
do you can have ice and now we can talk about Ben wellies.
Yeah,
let's talk bit more than two.
Shakespearian don't get crazy bad.
He's going to do a dual citizen.
So I'm hoping that you guys have an unusual,
that's a cool little friendship,
but working sort of friendship.
Yes,
it is unusual.
It's your best friend.
It's hard for a man and a woman and be friends.
It is,
but it also is,
it's a great balance.
You know what I mean?
Yes.
If it works,
right,
yeah.
Yeah it does.
And Yeah,
I feel really lucky because we're were like incredibly,
like our communicative skills or just,
we're very verbal,
we're very honest and you know,
I think something,
I think a lot of things with bands is being able to be like afraid sometimes and
talk about it or like fucked up about something and everyone,
you know,
wants any friendship.
Sure.
But this is a business too.
I mean it's a friendship and a business and more and more problematic.
It totally,
and it's anyhow,
it's,
it's a lot of,
you know,
there's a lot of emotions woven into this business too because you're creating
things and that there's a lot of attachment to that.
And um,
we just talk a lot,
you know,
we're have issues.
Like we're like,
you want to pursue a song and he's like,
I'm not really into it.
It's not working.
We,
we really are on the same page as far as like what works and what doesn't.
And we like,
if there's a tune that one of us brings to the table that we're not sure about
it,
we'll,
we'll give it a good try before it doesn't work.
And it's,
it's always like,
we just know,
you know,
we don't,
we don't fight about songs like that.
Vet Buddies would have been in bands and that always seems to be the giant
problem is the communication between band members that jockeying for position,
especially with dude's like for dudes,
it's like ultimately going to be some dick wave in contest between band members.
We wave our Dixon each other all the time.
What you mean my Dick in the
it's,
it's inevitable,
right?
I mean it's,
it's a rare thing.
When I was explaining or rather was,
I was asking you,
what is it like to have this rare friendship you guys have?
I mean it's rare that a man and a woman,
I mean you guys really seem like genuine friends.
There's not any weird creepy shit is a weird thing when you're hanging out with
siren noise and microphones booth.
Um,
you ever hang out with someone and there there's a guy and a girl and someone
likes someone and someone doesn't like the other person.
There's some weird fucking thing going on where,
you know,
for whatever reason,
you know what I mean?
It like,
it doesn't seem like a real friendship.
It's like this weird working partnership where the guy's creepy or the girls
creepy or someone's creepy because always something wrong.
But you guys both have like this,
like really liked both creepy you guys.
Is this easy way about you?
But I mean that,
that's,
um,
that's a very difficult thing to accomplish in this life.
Especially young.
You guys are very young.
You,
you said,
what'd you say?
28?
26.
And how old are you?
27.
I'm the one in the late twenties older woman.
I mean,
that's,
you know,
you're really young.
I mean,
to have your shit together this well,
you know,
and to be,
uh,
to be buddies like this and so collaborative,
you know,
without any weird ego shit that says a lot about the both of you.
I mean,
that's been a big part of everything we've done.
When she was talking earlier about what someone had said to her,
you know,
similar experiences,
not obviously,
not with the same adjectives.
No one was pushing me to be like the attractive one.
But,
uh,
you know,
there's,
there's a lot of getting over ego in this situation,
which I think is only served both of us,
you know what I mean?
Like,
uh,
just as much as that type of thing has happened to her.
You know,
I,
I tend to fade into the background where,
you know,
it sends a beautiful woman,
she's singing,
she's a front person,
blah,
blah.
Right.
And you know,
being able to be comfortable,
not,
not feeling threatened that no one gives a shit about what I'm doing or cares,
you know,
knows what I'm doing in the band has been something that has been great for me.
I feel like actually to get over that,
you know what I mean?
And not really,
you know,
be too invested in what people think they understand about
our relationship or anything like that.
This is going to end horribly wrong.
Oh boy.
She's going to completely fall apart at a certain point in time with,
no,
I'm terrified.
But you guys are the perfect little collaborative sort of a situation.
I mean,
it really is beautiful.
You know,
when,
when it sinks and it works,
you know,
it's obvious in what you produce,
what you're producing.
So,
so fascinating.
It was really compelling stuff.
It's really,
thank you.
Well,
And you know,
something that's like really important to us is um,
comedy and having fun and like,
there's a lot of serious elements to what we're doing because we want it so
badly to be our life and our career.
And you know,
obviously times are tough.
It's like,
you know,
we're not selling a million records right now and that'd be cool if we did.
Um,
but you know,
we're working our asses off and it's very rewarding.
And like if we're not having a blast,
if we're not having a blast and there's something wrong,
and even when we're like broke his shit,
which we totally are,
we're having so much fun.
Would you guys know the right now you're as legit as you'll ever be.
It's impossible.
Pretty much everything is going downhill.
When success hits you,
then it's like,
oh,
you know what?
I didn't even fucking respond your tweets anymore.
You know it's going to get,
you're in the,
you're in the perfect position because,
because once you become famous and once everything takes off,
then people are going to be looking at you like,
ah,
you know,
and you're just like fucking mainstream now.
It's like you're not the same.
You know what you were like right now you're like,
you're in your romantic prime and you guys are,
you remember that?
Just another band out of Boston on the road to try to make ends meet.
You ever heard that Boston song?
We were just another band out of Boston on the road to try to make ends meet
sleeping in our car.
I forget the fucking lyrics,
but the point is they did a show.
A guy came to this show and they got discovered.
You guys are like right there when the guy comes to the show and next thing you
know you're on the cover of Rolling Stone magazine with Matt Tie.
He be who was,
you don't know Matt Taibbi is?
No,
but he's the hunter s Thompson for 2012 but it's pretty cool.
Brilliant writer.
Wow.
A little mean a little on the mean side.
Andrew Breitbart died and the day he died,
he wrote an article called death of a douchebag.
The day he died.
And I was like,
wow,
he doesn't give a shit.
Yeah.
Well,
you know Matt,
Matt,
Matt Taibbi is fucking flock.
No,
no.
He,
he died natural causes.
No.
Breitbart died of natural causes and you know,
it's like,
wow,
Matt Taibbi doesn't give a fuck,
you know,
like that or,
or,
or it's a calculated move either way.
But the,
the thing is people were there.
It was a lot of people who were so upset about Breitbart's politics that they
didn't seem to mind at this happened that he died like that.
So I was like,
wow.
You know,
I was like,
wow,
Matt Taibbi is a bad mother fucker.
I can't believe you did that.
Hunters Thompson gave me shit.
Either he didn't.
And I don't agree with Matt Tie.
He'd be,
I would have never done that.
Even if it was worth it.
My worst enemy,
I would have never done that.
But a guy who's willing to do that.
Holy Shit,
that guy's got balls.
And I guess the point is like,
you know,
you're not forgive him for being a con just because you're dead
for good or for evil.
You know whether it's right or wrong,
neither should do me.
Yeah,
you,
you know,
look,
we should all be,
we should all be sorry for all the shitty things we've done while we're alive.
But just because you're dead doesn't mean we're supposed to reexamine your
existence.
Right?
I mean for your own good,
for the good of your own history.
It's,
it's better to keep things real.
Well I don't know.
Maybe you should reexamined cause then you have this ultimate perspective.
But at the same time,
if you were in fact a Douche bag,
then
you can't,
terrible feeling can change in the afterlife.
But at least you're in the clouds.
You're hanging out with harp dudes.
Why Harps and haven't please beautiful.
I'm having it doesn't get a violin.
Violence is really hard to learn.
And when you're learning it sounds like shit.
And when you've learned it and you haven't practiced it sounds like shit.
One of the things that I really like about your music is it make me,
made me remember how much I like songs with violins in them.
It's very rare.
Beg to differ with you.
This
beautiful instrument,
there's a powerful,
there's a,
there's a thing to a violin,
you know?
I mean there's like,
there's a reason why the devil went down to Georgia is such a bad ass song and
it's not because of guitars or drums.
It's a fucking violin man.
It's a violin battle.
It's a violent battle with the devil.
Okay,
Charlie,
this motherfucking Daniel's,
by the way,
in a violin battle with Satan.
You know,
come on man.
It's not a one one.
And anybody would say there's something wrong with the violin,
doesn't understand life,
you know,
it's not,
there's nothing wrong with the violin is with some wrong,
is the application of the violin,
the violin when properly applied,
is that a word?
Properly applied,
properly applied.
It's,
it's beautiful.
you guys use it a lot.
Use a violent a lot
lately.
Been using the Banjo a little bit more,
but it's in there.
It's woven in there.
What little threads of it you're,
you've got kind of like a little country sort of a thing going on,
like there's a lot of country influence to it.
Like a lot of stuff you do.
I think that the angel of death is it total throwback country tune stylistically
speaking.
What about let's get wrecked,
but that's,
that's not country.
That's more like rockabilly unfortunately.
Rock and roll.
Oh really?
I feel like we blew it on that song a little bit.
We did.
We're trying to rework the course isn't what it should hold.
Please shut the fuck up.
You guys are out of your mind
to just tell you how we really feel.
Well,
I know that you listen,
there's a lot of jokes,
jokes that I've recorded on CD and then like a month later and know how to do
them better.
I'm like,
fuck,
it's too late.
I know they're gone,
but he got accepted as a observer.
That's one of my favorite songs.
Do you guys have,
I love that song,
but you know it's funny.
It's like Bob Dylan rip off for sure.
Shit happens.
It sounds very Johnny Cash ish in the beginning.
Well,
they dug like the way there.
The writing is,
well,
there's a song called Bob Dylan's a hundred 15th dream,
uh,
which is on this,
it's bringing it back home as the record,
the name of the record and it's just like,
it's that I was,
we were just trying to write that song.
Literally.
Sorry.
What is Bob Dylan Son's name again?
Jacob.
Jacob wallflowers.
He's,
uh,
his kids were fear factor fans really.
And I got to meet him like way back in the day when fear factor was on TV,
you know,
as kids like wanting to meet me,
I was like,
Holy Shit,
I'm meeting pump Dylan's fucking song.
And that,
I really liked those guys too,
by the way.
I think there,
there are two albums are fucking amazing.
He wrote some really great,
there's one,
I got one of those ex-girlfriend songs,
you know,
or you can't listen to it because it's that one person in your life and it's
like,
boom.
It's like there's one song that that dude put out.
Wow.
That's this thing of the past.
Yeah.
Everybody's got a sting or more or what other stuff do you listen to?
You know what,
man,
I've got pretty eclectic tastes,
you know,
I'll be,
I like a lot of old shit for somebody.
I'm not a mean old.
I mean like seventies and sixties,
like American rock.
How dare you can't stay but by testicular output.
So Shiloh,
um,
a lot of like Leonard Skinner did a lot of shit.
I like a lot of like almond brothers Shit.
I'm like a lot of,
I like a lot of southern rock.
You know,
I like a lot of,
I think there's like,
it's like there's a bit of,
there's less pretension and more rhythm to a lot of southern rock that I really
like,
you know?
And I love,
uh,
I love like Leonard Leonard Skinner when they got big,
put out some of my favorite shit because it was all about getting the fuck away
from people.
Well,
there's songs,
10 songs,
get the fuck away from me.
I mean,
every song was,
I got to be free.
I'm a free bird.
Every fucking song was just like,
leave me alone.
Whoops.
You know,
Lord,
I can't change,
you know,
kind of go.
That's funny though.
They call me the breeze.
See?
I was like over and over and over again because all they're worried he's getting
tugged on by a billion people,
but they still had that,
you know that that southern rock flavor,
you know that there's like a twinkie Sorta,
you know,
like a more of a rhythmic thing to a lot of the southern rock
Stevie Ray Vaughan Vaughan,
he's the Shit God I that that was one of the dudes I never learned to play like
that,
but he was one of the guitar hero guys that I really connected with.
I used to listen to those records all the time to like Texas Flood Jews.
Come on,
man.
Couldn't stand the weather.
The live version.
I couldn't stand the weather.
When you,
you listened to that please everybody go get that Stevie labor on Rayvon live
with double trouble.
Right?
It was,
couldn't stand the weather.
Was this one,
the old one?
It was like an 83 or something before they don't remember what it was,
but there was a,
he had a bunch of live versions of songs that were really amazing.
One of them was a Voodoo child.
You ever heard him do Voodoo Child?
Oh my God.
It's one of the best versions of,
look,
I'm a huge Hendrix fan.
I mean the reason why we,
we called this the Joe Rogan experience,
total rip off with Jimi Hendrix.
Cause when I was a kid I was a huge Hendrix fan.
Like always the only guy who ever took a song that Hendricks did and put it in a
different place.
Not necessarily a better place,
but at different place was Stevie Ray Vaughan.
He has so much respect for Hendricks too.
That was the thing I think.
Yeah.
And Open respect.
And if his in his music videos,
he had like Hendrix posters in the back.
He liked loved Hendrix.
It wasn't like there was no,
there was no like swagger Jack and going on.
It was just like,
this is his version of it.
When did Stevie Ray Vaughan pass away in 95.
You don't almost got to drive him.
How's that limousine driver in Boston?
When I was,
when I,
she almost got to drive him.
Yeah.
I was 20,
19,
20,
somewhere around there.
And um,
the um,
he was touring with depth.
Jeff Beck and Jeff Beck got the van but Stevie Ray Vaughan
wouldn't get in any limousines.
He would only take cabs.
Huh.
So he like,
yeah,
he didn't like being in limos.
It's was like this is creeping.
Maybe we get in cabs cause he likes to talk to people in smoke cigarettes.
That's cool.
Even cooler,
you got to check out,
you know,
Gary Clark Jr you gotta check out here every once in a while.
And Stevie Ray Vaughan was one of these guys who brought blues to a point where
the mainstream could really appreciate it.
And I feel like Gary Clark Jr is doing that right now.
Gary Clark Jr he's the,
he's the real deal.
I got into a female singers when I was a kid because a while was doing a martial
arts competitions and kickboxing.
I would always look for something that was like the opposite of that.
Something that was like calming,
you know,
because it's really cool.
Yeah.
Well I think,
yeah,
I read the book of five rings.
It's a book by this Guy Miyamoto Musashi,
who was a,
a Great Samurai and killed like 62 men and one on one battles,
but sword fighting and shit.
And um,
he,
he wrote this thing and it's called the book of five rings and what the Book of
five rings is,
it's a book on how to live life and it's basically all about balance.
And one of the things that he proposed that every Samurai should also be an
artist and you should be well versed in poetry and they,
you should be able to express yourself.
There should be no holes in your ego and she'd be no kinks in your game.
Wow.
And so when I was competing,
I recognize that my,
you know,
as a man,
you're your biggest insecurity when you're young,
especially,
it's like a weakness.
Any sort of weakness,
whether it's low,
like I used to even literally think that sex like pleasure was a weakness,
you know,
because,
well,
no,
it wasn't even that it was fighting.
It was a discipline issue is desire.
Discipline.
It was exactly,
it was.
Yeah,
it was,
it was the,
uh,
the,
not just desire but pleasure.
Like you don't need pleasure bitch,
get out,
run,
go run hills in the now.
And so this,
this,
this book sort of,
uh,
introduced my head to the idea of relaxing some of my cave man bullshit and
appreciating like the feminine aspects of things.
So the first thing I started getting into it was like women singers.
And so I was like,
uh,
I think it was like 18 or 19 years old when I got into like a Ricky Lee Jones
Chucky's and love dude,
that's a great got down song.
She was a bad ass bitch.
Oh fuck yeah.
You kidding me?
We play,
you're no good.
All the time on this show.
We played it to the point where I got,
I got mad at him.
I got huge diamond Ross Fan.
Big nipples.
Yeah.
It looks like Diana Ross right now.
Oops.
There's a lot of guys,
man.
When I,
when I told you,
uh,
you know,
when I,
when I tweeted,
you know,
all these guys are the shit,
check out this video and I put one of your videos up.
I got called a home.
I'll at least a hundred people
it looks like,
let's do they're afraid though.
It's fucking terrified to fluky.
There's something about a guy liking like something weak and soft.
Like,
Oh,
I love cuddles.
Loke Hawk.
Fuck that pussy.
You know what?
Every,
every,
every strong man,
every like when you get sick,
you still get the fucking sniffles.
It's true.
Bracing,
like how you're thinking.
I've got it made sense.
You know what I mean?
Like you can,
you can act tough.
You can be as tough as you want to be,
but when you're sick,
you get the sniffles and you may like it and you make movies
in the answer twice a day.
If you're lucky,
you're lucky.
Take your neighbor
Broccoli.
You don't,
you might have issues.
Yeah.
Right?
And in the end we're all dead anyway.
What the fuck?
So you know,
it takes a,
there's a certain amount of time that you need to live on this light before you
sort of accept the fact that,
you know,
just kind of enjoy this and realize that none of it makes any fucking sense.
You know,
I don't want to go backwards here,
but you were really,
you really impressed and inspired me when you were talking about this book of
five rings and in martial arts and like,
you know,
you would think you would think that
that's correct.
Musashi.
Yeah.
Beautiful.
That's really beautiful.
Yeah.
This was this Guy Aaron Dellavedova from grew tattoo in San Diego.
Did it.
But that's what it is.
Minimum Miyamoto Musashi.
But I,
I mean,
I think there's something that's it,
it's true wisdom when you can have a balance of calm within,
within the arena of,
um,
I don't want to say war cause that sounds really dramatic,
but,
but like when you're,
um,
in,
I don't want to in battle,
but in the,
in the proverbial sense if it just like competition pressure,
but like in life in general,
you know what I mean?
Because there's a lot of shit out there,
especially if you're doing something like that or like even when you play a
show,
like where you have to,
you have to center yourself and it's really easy to,
um,
want to just die.
You got to check the pool for water before you dive in.
You know what I mean?
It's like,
it's really easy to just go into situations in any capacity,
in any facet,
whether it's you're going to work or you're in a competition or you're playing a
rock show or you're dating.
Yeah.
Without,
without that is sometimes a fucking wrestling matches.
[inaudible] kidding me.
Good God,
I'm in my late twenties.
I know,
but,
but seriously,
early,
late twenties.
Thank you Ben.
That's really nice of you to redeem yourself after calling me old in the cow.
Take that bar.
You got to take that.
You can see,
I'm sorry.
Thank you.
Fresh and mark with the condition always.
Yeah,
it came my ideas of chasing down like a balance came at a very purely selfish
reasons.
Initially it was just,
I didn't want to get my ass kicked.
It was that simple.
It's just like to,
to,
to compete better.
I feel,
I felt like I needed to balance myself out.
I'm really kind of a weird way to approach it,
but to me it's the only thing that made sense.
It's like,
I tried meditation,
I did that as well,
but there was like,
there was other stuff that needed to be addressed as well.
You know,
we,
I have you been competing your whole,
I mean
when I was growing up,
like in high school I did mostly,
you know,
until I started doing standup comedy and that's when I was like 21 or 22.
So when when I started doing that,
then I just like completely,
uh,
abandoned the idea of a competition.
I was just sort of doing that at that point.
I have momentum.
I'd done it like so much when I was a young kid,
you know,
but the,
there's a lot of shit that comes out of martial arts that is clearly and
directly applied to,
uh,
to,
to art,
to any form of art.
You know,
and it's from that Musashi book,
you know,
the idea that you,
there was so much,
well that's fascinating about that book was this guy that lived,
you know,
hundreds and hundreds of years ago.
He was basically a man who would go and have one on one battles to the death
with other men.
So he could have no weakness.
He could have no imbalance in his,
in his thought process and his ability to,
to,
you know,
to objectively look at any situation.
He had to really be aware of what his strength and weaknesses are,
how to improve upon himself.
And so this was his approach,
you know?
And I just always found that like,
who who faced crazier shit than this guy in life,
61 on one source
because you fucking a man.
But I think it's amazing.
No,
please.
I said,
I think it's amazing that someone who is so successful and all that stuff was so
focused on accepting the entirety of himself.
You know what I mean?
Because,
yeah,
exactly.
It's like,
then if you aren't repressing certain avenues of yourself,
I don't see how that would be an unsuccessful.
Do you want,
I think we,
we,
a lot of us,
you know,
human beings,
we require something to imitate.
We require,
uh,
someone who leads by example.
And,
uh,
oftentimes we're left in situations where it's all peripheral.
Like the people that lead by example,
they might be on television or in movies.
You're not,
sorry,
how much of that is bullshit,
but are your examples that you're reaching and everyday life they're not,
they're not good.
They're not good examples of people.
So,
you know,
what are your,
what you,
what are you imitating?
I mean the tribe imitates,
you know,
the big buzz of the hive.
I mean if you look at like Japan,
it's a perfect example.
I just got back from there.
Super Polite,
strange alien culture or everyone's nice and everyone's height,
height.
Everywhere you go,
everyone is super polite and you're like,
why did this happen?
How did this happen?
Because somehow or another they,
they engender this type of thinking and a gotten a buzz and then everybody just
copied everybody else and then it became what it is.
It became what it is was planted,
it grew and now it is what it is.
But you know,
that's not,
that's,
it's not easy to pull off a Japan.
It's not easy to pull it off with Japan,
but it is what we will,
we need.
Well one of the things we need,
especially when we're young,
we need examples.
We need other,
we need someone else to imitate.
We need someone else to say we need someone that shows.
It's why we love heroes.
It's why we love,
you know,
the great heroes of movies.
I mean,
Joseph Campbell stories,
it's all the idea behind it is all that we need someone to aspire to so that we
realize the weaknesses of our own,
you know,
insecurities.
Our,
our,
our own dissatisfaction with who we are.
Yeah.
You know,
cat,
it's just too much.
No,
this is amazing.
this is deep.
It's too much.
It's an interesting thing because your,
your perspective going to a place like Japan,
you're,
you're going there as a successful entertainer,
you know what I mean?
And that also,
not to challenge your perceptions at all,
but your perspective is,
uh,
someone who people in that environment are looking to please as well.
You know what I mean?
That's definitely a good point.
But,
um,
uh,
I really,
I saw it amongst everyone everywhere.
Yeah.
The way I,
I really,
um,
I,
I watched a lot of people,
I sat down,
I sat down in the hotel lobby for a long time,
one day just watching people interact with each other.
And there were,
there were so polite,
so amazing and everyone's like slightly bowing to each other.
And Hi.
Hi.
Everyone is just really trying to be super accommodating.
The security at the,
the,
uh,
arena could not have been polite or you were easily by far right Brian easiest
too.
I get past the security also.
Remember that?
Yeah.
Well they didn't understand that Brian was with me.
You know,
I have these,
uh,
these passes and it's supposed to be like,
you know,
like just leave me alone.
You know,
there's a big pass.
I know what I'm doing and you know,
when I'm,
I'm trying to move the guy through,
I'm like,
he's with me.
It's okay.
He's with me.
And they just didn't know what the fuck that meant.
Yeah.
In,
in America,
we do it all the time.
Know everyone knows every,
you know,
it's cool.
But you know,
in,
in Japan they didn't know what was going on.
So I was like,
it's okay.
It's okay.
They're like,
okay.
You sure it was this weird communication.
Like they didn't understand English.
We kind of put,
but they were so polite.
They just let us go by cause nobody,
it's not,
I mean,
I want to say nobody like would bullshit their way there.
But it's much more uncommon than it is in America.
You can never just let a guy come up.
Do you go out?
I gotta go over there real quick.
Yeah.
Hi.
Suzanne lived in.
This is something I love about Suzanne.
She lived in Tokyo.
What?
She was like 16
as a model.
Yeah.
How dare you hang out with the Russians.
I didn't,
I had some Russian friends.
Yeah.
Wow.
What was that like?
Um,
you know,
it was,
I was 16.
I was so young.
Oh,
who the fall let you go then when you were 16 parents.
Why?
What the fuck man,
folks,
let me move to New York when I was 16 to,
you know,
this,
it's like there's,
there's details.
Like they,
they,
they were with me for a lot of the times.
My,
again,
I'm sorry,
come on man.
But you know,
culturally speaking for,
for Japan,
um,
there was it,
it's definitely jolting.
Especially when I was that young going,
you know,
over 10 years ago,
Jesus,
I'm old.
I'm sorry.
This dumb.
No,
you didn't,
you just were there when you were a baby.
Say like over 10 years ago it was,
it's very weird,
but yeah,
but you were fucking 16.
I was,
that's crazy.
what's that about what it was your mom thinking?
Just get her,
you know what my folks,
they were really know.
My parents are,
are really amazing people.
Yeah.
They were super supportive.
You by you being a model of Japan?
Not that they've always done.
They've known that.
I,
I have,
I've been driven with things like,
I've always had things,
you know,
like I grew up doing a lot of musical theater and I sing in a choir and I played
in orchestra and,
and I just would work my ass off like this.
Things that I loved and they,
I attribute a lot of my opportunities to the,
their support because they were never like,
no,
you can't do that.
You're too young.
They were just like,
yeah,
let's do this.
They minded.
They were great.
Yeah.
They still are.
You know,
I,
uh,
they live in Ohio,
but they,
um,
you know,
I,
oh wait.
Yeah.
It's okay.
I've got a lot of,
what do they do?
What does your dad do?
What was your mind?
My family owns a restaurant,
an Italian restaurant,
yet might,
my grandparents started it in what's called Santo on this crazy journey to be a
model in Japan at 16 years old.
I started locally in Cleveland.
I was in like value city department store heads growing up.
And how long would you occasionally,
it'll be like totally mortifying because I'd be in like a Dick's sporting goods,
add in a sports bra and I go to high school whenever everyone
like,
Hey,
I saw you in your training bro.
I'm like,
do you look for athletes?
Wow.
You Jackass.
Um,
but no,
they,
they let me,
they let me go.
Um,
I,
I was scouted by an agency when I had previously spent my summer in Chicago when
I was 15,
which is so funny cause like the agency was like,
there's going to be chaperones and you guys,
they're going to live in like a model's apartment and there's people there.
And like,
I did whatever I wanted and I was going to bars and I was,
it was crazy.
It was crazy.
But you know,
I did.
I didn't,
I was like,
you know,
I was still a virgin till then.
Just a real personal,
I have three daughters.
Don't freak me out.
I'm not,
I'm not.
No,
no.
You know what,
just talk to read.
Dot.
I talked to Doc.
Talk to him like crazy,
bro.
Suzanne has two sisters,
three sisters,
four girls in my family.
Are you the oldest?
The youngest?
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
They've given up by then of course,
the leg.
Of course they let you go.
Jesus Christ.
That's ridiculous.
If you're a baby,
number one,
I want to tell you what,
it never made that fucking trip thrown in the towel.
Well,
no,
it's not even that.
It's the tail.
It had been terrified of losing you,
but by the time they got down to you,
they were like,
let her free.
Go ahead.
Japan sounds reasonable.
I heard they're nice.
Japanese people are polite.
Good luck there kid.
Wow.
What's the longest time you stayed there?
Uh,
I was there for like two months.
Wow.
My whole summer basically.
Whoa.
Anything creepy ever happened?
Um,
in a lot of creepy stuff.
But nothing that was like,
nothing that was dangerous or bad for me,
but just like in enticing,
um,
I gross,
enjoyable.
So I vomiting.
This is the funny part.
So I,
I don't know if I should talk about that.
Sure.
Aleisha so,
so I did the one and only time that I've ever done ecstasy was in Japan and I
was with,
I was with this incredibly beautiful professional boxer from New Zealand.
And so basically like we did ecstasy.
Do you have a song written about this thing?
No,
no,
no.
We made out,
right.
We ate,
we ate popsicles and watching the matrix and like later as an adult,
I look back and I'm like,
I can't believe like I didn't get raped or something or,
you know what I mean?
Like I totally like,
you know,
that was it.
It was like totally innocent.
And like literally when I got off the plane I was like,
Hey mom,
dad,
I had a really good time in Japan.
I tried ecstasy.
It's still a virgin.
Everything's good.
Like I told him about the messages you can look for and like everything's fine.
You know?
It sounds like an amazing game show.
Yeah.
You might be the coolest chick of all time.
You want to do that tonight?
We don't have to wake up early.
It's going to be that kind of party.
Actually.
I think we do do it.
Why do you guys have like what's going on now?
You guys know concerts going on big.
A lot of big shows.
You were saying that you were showing Santa Monica that you're nervous about
your upcoming shit.
We,
well we have a lot of things coming up but you know it's funny,
Newport folk festival people are listening and they were asking us to talk about
that.
But yeah,
people
shut their pie hole.
What you were talking about because the honey honey band at Twitter.
Okay.
All the information should be in your background.
Put that shit up on your back wall,
your wallpaper,
you know.
Well,
so when people go to view entire profile,
go to honey honey,
band.com is that it?
Is that what your ad is it everybody always wants you to like really focus on
their thing though.
Well,
you know,
we've got a big summer.
That is a great festival though.
It is.
They're all great.
We're fucking pumps.
We know we have,
we have great stuff coming up.
We're playing south by South West,
which is next week.
Is that true?
That they just like,
they don't don't pay for plane tickets.
They don't want to pay for shit.
But no,
we're not going to pitch
our asses on that word.
But you know what?
Damn good time losing our ass.
I'm sure you are.
But isn't that a little odd that south by south,
my friend Duncan Trussell,
he's a standup comedian,
got invited to south by southwest and he,
he had no idea that this was the case.
And he said this is the most preposterous fucking thing of all time.
It's like this is like a big financial success and they're not paying anybody.
And so he made this whole video of Hitler screaming and yelling.
He's like yelling at people and in the,
you know,
you don't know what the Fuck Hitler says unless you speak Germany,
German,
Germany,
China as a country.
And he was,
so he's got,
he's got in subtitles in English,
all the different things about can you fucking believe how south by southwest
works?
You know how ridiculous it is that they just fly you up.
I mean,
you,
they don't even fly you out there.
They don't do any,
give you room ticket and at least give you a drink
bottle.
They,
well that means that's the bit,
that means that somebody is donating bottles.
But,
but they south by south west kind of like a,
uh,
a morphous thing.
It's like we're,
we're playing shows.
None,
none of them,
none of the shows were playing our south by southwest.
There are people who are,
have kind of venue set up at south by south.
Oh,
I see.
Yeah.
So it's,
you know,
it's a,
it's a crazy thing.
My friend Doug stand helps you to do that with um,
the Montreal comedy festival.
The Montreal comedy festival used to be called just for laughs and it was like
the big industry festival.
It's still is sort of,
and uh,
he would do just for spite and do it the exact same time that they would do it
and do his own shows in town.
Just sort of piggy backing.
Funny.
So is that sort of like that kind of a thing?
Like everybody like gathers in that town,
he put all kinds of shows happen in the town.
I mean it's a convention.
It's a real cool,
like that's what it's based on.
And that's the reality of it is a convention.
How many people pay attention to that aspect of it?
But all these people,
everyone from the industry just comes in and wants to showcase.
How would it be cool if they just paid for your plane ticket and your hotel
room?
You know,
I mean look,
you know,
if you really want to operate in the idea that it's a huge publicity and I guess
it martial arts,
you know,
sweet moves,
no one wants to pay for shit that you mean that
the Internet is your friend.
These companies are not your friend.
The Internet's your friend.
The Internet.
Get your,
your information,
your music,
your thoughts,
your ideas,
your best shit delivered way better than any of these fucking crazy people and
some weird town that want to fucking put up tents.
That's not it.
But we've had some crazy experiences with Dezin outside of Indianapolis.
What happened to the days of Denver?
Actually Denver too.
Basically we pretty much banned one more stuck,
like when we're driving like 18 hours or whatever the fuck.
And we get to that point where we're like,
just stop anywhere.
It doesn't matter if there's a days inn,
don't go ever.
Wow.
Sorry.
Brian knows the worst craisins before.
I've had no issues when though Joe back in the design has changed you saying
that,
but I don't think you can generalize.
How many days is have you stayed in?
Give me a number 30 bed to for to now.
Okay.
That's not enough to judge.
No,
you're right.
That's a Nielsen number.
We have a hundred percent fucking creep us out.
It was a crack house.
That does happen occasionally.
Cleveland
podcast.
Why I don't give a fuck it good cause listen,
first of all,
it's not meat.
It's saying it.
It's really clear that this is
funny.
Honey,
run this through a computer and this for sure.
That's not my voice.
We've had,
we've had,
we went to day's inn.
This is in Denver.
Um,
first of all that the man in front of me,
uh,
booking his room and days inn was buying condoms with loose change.
This is not true.
Not An exaggeration.
When we got up to the room,
somebody was in our room,
somebody room knock on the door.
Hey,
we're two 17.
Oh,
okay.
And then he scurried off,
not a joke.
And then as we were realizing this was not the position for us to be and we are
leaving some dude in two 13 try to pick a fight with me.
I said,
came out of the shadows.
Fucking came at me.
Whoa.
What did he say to you?
Been out of something about me being pussy probably.
I Dunno,
I shrimped out.
No worries.
How dare you,
Ben,
your pocket.
Listen,
I need you guys to,
I need you guys for inspiration.
Listen,
I will do whatever you guys need me to do except anal that
Brian is just,
that's what he does.
He's a human train wreck.
He's,
he's fucking boards on a railroad track.
Right?
Okay.
It's creating problems.
Oh,
Brian.
Yeah.
We need to make that shirt.
Yep.
We'll keep talking about it.
We need to make a shirt that says no Brian,
because he does this every podcast that's sort of his job.
Oh
wait,
so something completely inappropriate and only his Ohio mine could figure out
why are
you guys gonna play the angel dough?
You want to hear it?
Fuck yeah.
Tune up your shit.
I'm going to be,
oh,
this is the most we've ever repeating any podcasts.
Blame alcohol.
Yeah,
we should do that.
Is the sound of a violin beat tomb phone?
It sounds like my ex wife.
What does that mean?
Are you married right now?
Oh.
Did you ever play violin?
And I knew I played trumpet best scene keyboard.
Do you have any of those incidents with you?
If you'd like to play along with us.
I don't have him anymore and I don't know how to play anymore.
Hold on now.
I'm good.
I lost of it.
If I play like this,
is that going to be like,
can I play up to this guy or ship liquid back?
You can play whatever you want.
Okay.
This is how do I make this thing work?
I'm moving.
Sorry.
Went to the,
uh,
application APP now.
Do you find that's accurate enough?
I,
I'd be honest.
I can't tell the difference.
Yeah,
that's a machine and I am but a man,
try that.
Have you guys been back to Ohio lately?
You know what?
I went back to Ohio for a month over Christmas and it was awesome.
We played a show.
That's great.
Um,
I'm in the Cleveland area.
Is the flat still around?
I heard no,
I turned even there anymore.
Many people got drunk and drowned in the river.
Yeah.
So that is,
um,
uh,
yeah,
it's real.
When I met Suzanne,
one of the first things she did is tell me about how she met drew Carey.
Oh.
And she ran up to true Carrie and said,
hi drew Carey.
I'm Suzanne.
I just want to tell you that I'm really proud of you.
And everything you've done for cleaning.
I love you so much.
And nobody pimps Cleveland harder than you.
Is that what she said?
Yeah,
and he tweeted back like I tweeted at him and he retweeted our tweet.
Drew Carey's one of the nicest guys I've ever met,
especially in Hollywood.
He's such a great guy.
I was around him once,
he was at the Improv and uh,
I'll,
I'll never forget what he did.
He uh,
there was some kids that were like just starting out.
They were like open makers and someone asks something,
I don't know.
I don't know what it was at some,
someone asks him sort of a standup comedy related question and drew Carey like
made a a point of like look at him in the eye and go,
listen,
just write one joke every day.
Every day.
Just make yourself right.
One joke at the end of the week,
you got seven new jokes,
just write one.
And he was like,
like in the kid was like mystified.
Like,
Holy Shit,
this is drew Carey.
He was an open miker and true.
Carrie's going,
listen,
just write one joke every day.
You can do that,
right?
One is sit down,
right.
One joke,
he had a big smile on his face and
he's very present.
He's a nice guy.
You're listening to me.
And then like I was one who was a babbling idiot.
Like I,
it kind of threw me off that he was like,
hi,
how are you?
Really warm.
And I was like,
okay,
so gotta go buy.
It was totally insane.
Which is
good because it's almost accurate.
It's possible to stay nice person in this crazy world.
It's possible not full as drew Carey made us,
sorry interrupt.
Sorry.
No,
please,
please.
Do you,
I mean like when I think about sitting down and writing a joke,
I don't under,
you know,
like it feels like,
I mean I made this stupid because the right songs,
you know,
so it's the same thing,
but like do you,
have you been through that period where you sit down and write a joke a day?
Are you every single day you try to write something?
Well,
what I do one of three things.
One one is I start just by just responding to people on Twitter and like looking
for uh,
interesting things that people were tweeting me.
It's always some weird fucking thing.
A guy got eaten by a crocodile and this,
this thing happened here.
And then they got some new way to develop sperm in a lab.
And there's that.
There's always a little bit of that.
So I'll do that for like maybe 20 minutes.
And then what I do is I just a,
I just write like essays.
I just sat down and,
and whatever it is I start with,
it doesn't matter.
I could start with talking about,
you know,
this is why it's good to get trunk and I'll just just start,
just whatever the fuck comes out of my head.
I just need a starting point.
I need,
I need to somewhere to press the green light and then I just start writing.
And as much as it comes out as possible,
and then,
uh,
I have to go back and sort of dissect it and then I take chunks out of it and
then throw those chunks in.
And then those chunks become like,
it,
it all condensed as it goes through like a filtration process.
When then it becomes like don't,
don't,
don't punch line,
you know.
And,
and sometimes no,
sometimes like you,
you have to go through like long set up things for like more complex ideas.
But for the most part that's what it all,
what would stand up all comes down to for me.
But,
but everybody has a different way or writing,
you know.
I mean do you think about rhythm when you say it cause you want to,
you just went do,
do,
do punch that.
Yes.
I'll definitely,
yeah man,
rhythm is very important.
Timing is to reporting and it's a very intuitive thing,
you know,
and it requires a lot of repetition requires you doing the material many,
many times to sort of gauge what feels false about it.
You know,
like when you have an idea,
like a lot of times like Brian's don't love stand up to,
and he can back me up on this because he's,
it's Brian and actually be a good person to talk about this with because he's
um,
he's relatively sort of new to comedy.
He,
he,
he tried it a long time ago and it took a long time off and then it really
jumped back in and start doing like bigger shows with us and doing a lot of
shows here so he knows what it's like.
So,
so tell him
about writing jokes.
Yeah,
I just,
pretty much something happens that I find funny.
Like I laugh and I'll go,
that's pretty funny that,
and so I tried to,
I write it down in my notes and then later just kind of think I actually do it
the wrong way.
I just kind of think of like an idea in my head,
write down the notes so I remember it.
And then right before I go onstage and just kind of go like,
all right,
am I talking about that?
All right,
well do you know that's not the wrong way you say it's the wrong way.
It's not the wrong way because it's a pressure filled situation that sometimes
works.
Right.
You know,
I was on a Sitcom and the 90s,
it was his call,
it was called news radio and it was um,
one of the most interesting things about it is the guy who created it,
this Guy Paul Sams,
really brilliant guy.
And um,
one of the things he would do is they would not write anything until like three
in the morning.
Like it was like at 10:00 AM they knew that there was going to be a table read,
but they had written shit.
There's like a few things written down in there farting on each other and
playing video games.
And then at like three in the morning they'd be like,
fuck,
we got to write this grant.
And then they would write like 90% of the time,
maybe I'm going to be really honest,
maybe 80% of the time it'd be absolutely fucking brilliant.
20% of the time would just,
they would just,
they would,
there were too tired and they couldn't get through it.
This is how it goes get anyway.
Right?
Yeah.
But it's that pressure pressure of forcing yourself into a situation where
you're just going to go and talk about something and try to figure out what's
funny.
Sometimes little things blossom out of that.
So you say it's the wrong way to do it,
but that's the way I,
I've done it.
I think it's
good way to do it.
And another thing is it's like taking these little things and then combining
them finding like,
like that's what I've been doing lately where I find find something funny and I
it on stage and I find something else funny to say onstage and then I've tried
to find a way to,
I could put those two things together,
no one and make a bigger one.
And it's kind of like,
I don't know,
it's like mine craft.
See the difference between us and you guys.
I think a big part of it is that we need an audience to practice is very
important.
You can't practice with it.
I was just going to ask you that.
So yeah,
100% it's so important with the,
you know,
that's why I'm like,
so I always like go way out of my way to thank people and wait after shows and
take pictures of the people.
Like I can't even practice without them.
I need them for the whole thing.
The only thing that I could do is write concepts that I'm pretty sure funny,
but I need them to be there to craft it because there's a rhythm that you get in
when you have people's attention.
It's very different than the rhythm that you have when you're alone.
You know,
you have to sort of like try to like replicate it,
you know,
as you're sitting alone.
But you guys can come up with a fucking awesome song,
you know,
and then just launch it,
at people and it's already done like whoa.
Like that's impossible for a comedian.
A comedian can only have like rough drafts.
You go up on stage at some,
some,
you know,
you have the ideas of how it's going to work and you sort of PR,
I mean you have some punchlines that you've sorta preestablished in your hat of
being probable or profitable or you know,
hopeful.
You know,
like this,
this is going to fucking,
this is money baby,
you know,
and then sometimes he dropped them and
work.
There's also a lot of times where it seems like you feel like you want this bit
to work or your service and price.
It doesn't work.
You don't want to give up on it.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
And there's also sometimes we,
you say it once one time and it's just the perfect moment where the stars have
magically aligned and the rhythm of the room is correct and it's just,
they wanted to laugh at the right moment and they,
and it,
it,
it nailed it,
but it really wasn't that good.
And you gotta like,
you gotta let that Shit Cow.
Do you guys feel that?
What songs do you have songs that you get to a certain point in time when you're
like,
this is just going to throw this one away?
Yeah,
for sure.
We've let songs go alive.
Courting is kind of like the,
uh,
the end all.
I think that that's Kinda like the brick wall and everything gets thrown up
against and if it doesn't pass through it doesn't make it.
And we've had a lot of songs that have,
we've,
we've played regularly live.
And then when it comes down to recording it,
which means like confronting what you're actually playing,
then it doesn't make it through it,
you know.
What is the,
um,
the issue that you guys have with let's get wrecked?
The chorus,
the chorus.
I don't think it's the chorus.
I think it's the,
I think it's the guitar playing.
Really
kidding.
No,
it's,
you know,
we're,
we're reading I think,
cause we liked
it at one point.
We were all fucking,
you know,
over the moon about it.
But we're are just like,
you know,
we were talking about jokes changing and things like that.
We're,
we're going a little more,
we're getting a little harder and like just blues kind of,
and it's a little more,
I don't,
I don't want to say kitschy cause that's really insulting,
but it's more like,
it's almost like we need to make it a little more mature.
Does that sound okay?
Well,
I feel like that record was a rush.
You know what I mean?
We,
we had to make a record so we made this record and you know,
just like with jokes or with anything developed.
Yeah.
That,
that was something that we,
we did in committed to and I don't regret doing it at all,
but you know,
at,
at this point,
you know,
given some time to marinade or whatever,
wouldn't have made the same choices.
You know?
I think that's a part of the process though.
Anything I completely,
absolutely.
He kind of have to have stuff that's out there that doesn't really represent who
you are today,
otherwise you're not moving forward.
Yeah.
There's a lot of acts at a certain point in their careers.
They,
it becomes the,
the older stuff.
It represents like the best example of who we are.
And so they're not embarrassed about it at all.
In fact,
they look at it nostalgically look,
that's back when they were really putting it together.
That's a funny thing.
Sorry.
No,
you first.
All right,
well that's life,
right?
It is.
But I feel like if I had a goal on how to live,
I would,
I would make the good stuff come afterwards.
I think just,
I mean,
the progression of the universe.
I mean that's,
that's the sort of how it all works.
Well that's true.
Everything.
Do you know,
I think it's,
it's good to be truthful with where you're at.
Like I listened to our first record the other day for the first time in a long
time and I was like,
no.
Like I was embarrassed in my,
like in my weird,
like,
you know,
just analyzing myself and be like,
oh,
that was,
I could have done this,
this and this.
And I seen it like this now and my voice is better now.
And,
but you know,
that's again,
that's,
that was,
that was my truth at the time.
And I think in,
in an,
for me goes so deep in,
in life in general,
to be truthful with where you're at is a really rewarding thing.
And you know,
as an artist when you look back it's really easy to be hard on yourself.
But um,
you know,
to give myself a hard time is wasteful,
it's just good to just,
yeah,
you don't want to give yourself a hard time about the past.
But uh,
I,
it's,
it's a,
that's a big part of why what you're doing right now is so good.
It's like,
it all sort of like this sort of distaste for shit that doesn't sort of like
really resonate with you or good.
It just feels like I'm faking this are forcing this or that sort of distaste is
what leads you to,
you know,
to greater heights.
Like this gross feeling is like so necessary.
It's like,
it's really,
you know,
an order to have like such a depth to what you're saying,
what you're doing.
You have to have gone through like a full spectrum of feelings and thoughts on
things.
And I think that's what your,
your music resonates with like a lot of thinking like that La River Song,
man,
that's,
that's another song really love.
It's like the lyrics are like,
it,
it speaks of someone who's thinking,
you know what I'm saying?
It's not just,
you could say a certain amount of words in a row and it's just a song and a few
things rhyme and,
and then neither clicks with my head or it doesn't,
but there's certain twists and turns in the narrative.
There's certain twists and turns and how you're describing things that just,
you know,
as a,
as a person,
like that's like,
that's what you hope that you can do to somebody as a person.
You hope that you could put something out there,
whatever the fuck it is.
It's your,
your apple cupcakes or
you're fucking,
you know what I'm saying?
You get the mass back massages.
You know,
whenever you fix a car better than anybody,
you just hope that
or another you knock someone on their ass like that La River song does.
Electing a lot of your shit does.
It's a,
that what that represents to me is just like Miyamoto Musashi saying once you
understand the way you see it in all things,
once you see,
once you see it in one thing,
once you understand it broadly,
you see it in all things.
The idea said that too.
Everything is,
everything is the crazy,
you know,
I don't know,
maybe I'm just trunk.
Definitely.
You're very emotional,
emotional today,
right?
I'm on my period.
You're just,
you're,
you're totally in a different Joe that then you are,
well,
you know,
I think,
I dunno man.
I just been thinking a lot lately about,
um,
the idea of a,
just the idea of sort of just interacting with human beings,
you know,
and what it really all is,
and how,
how bizarre it is that there's,
there's a certain,
there's a certain thing that happens when we connect with people in a very
positive way and it's,
it's sort of an accelerant and it's sort of a,
a feeling of like everything is moving in the right direction.
We all sort of instinctively know when that's happening.
And that's like when I feel like when you guys are here,
when,
when you know,
when you guys are here and you're playing music and I'm like,
Holy Shit.
Like we put all this together.
Like we didn't have anybody that helped us out here.
We put all this together.
I met you guys,
you know,
uh,
I talked about you online,
we talked back to each other,
balls of steel,
hooked it all up.
We go back and forth and then boom,
blood farts seven.
Thank you guys on a real guy.
Is it?
Yeah.
It's kind of like there's this fabric of interesting connection between people
that the more you kind of sort of let it happen.
It's really an interesting experience in life.
Like people come in and they tend,
everybody's a part of it,
right?
It's a fucking hundred balls of steels out there.
All steel we're looking for you,
man,
is,
we're going to hold
the part about it.
With that in mind,
there's a hundred or more,
way more than that.
Incredible bands.
You know what I mean?
Our position playing incredible.
How many guys are like you out there.
Be honest with packs out there and there's none.
There's only one.
Ben Jaffe and I'm sorry,
I'm going to test it out.
This man is a one of them.
I mean like if you're not a standup comedy fan the first time you ever come to a
comedy club,
I bet he is.
He's a smart guy.
Sorry.
Well you can like Musashi said,
concentrate on that and I'm sure you'd be a great comedian if that's what your
calling was,
have you,
if you,
I really think that's really what it is.
I mean everyone,
you know,
your,
your certain did essences of the various ingredients of your personality.
It might lead you in one direction or the other.
But I really believed that if you had chosen to be great at anything,
that you'd be great at anything.
If you,
if you
hip national basketball,
right?
Maybe not.
Maybe not me,
but I'm not,
I,
I before,
I don't think we knew everyone,
what people called talent on thinks it's a specific thing,
I think is a focus.
Um,
you know,
it is a little bit,
yeah,
but this is certain dudes that are talented in a strange,
bizarre ways,
you know,
physically talented,
especially like athletes.
There's some,
I've met athletes like there is no way you can't tell that they're absolutely
physically talented and gifted.
If they're not normal people,
they can do weird shit.
They can jump through the air way higher than anybody in a good run quicker than
anybody.
They grab you at stronger.
This is no getting around that,
you know.
So there's,
there's a certain amount of like physical and athletic talent at a certain
amount of like vocal talent.
I can't sing at all.
I'll never be able to say I my voice.
You have a voice.
Do you know what I mean?
Like there's,
there's a difference and it's not a difference.
Actually.
I think that,
um,
Oh God,
this is really intense and I'm like candy,
but I kind of want to say this.
I think when people have these,
um,
these gifts in life,
whether it's athleticism or,
um,
just a brilliant mind or you know,
martial arts or acting or music,
whatever,
um,
there's always an opportunity for an awareness of the other people around you
and how you connect to them with these gifts.
And I think some people have theirs,
it's a closed door and it's just their gift in their,
maybe their ego or whatever.
And then there's the other people that just understand that it's all part of a
bigger thing.
Like,
you know,
there's a,
I think there's a reason that you're able to reach over a half million people
cause you,
you have a lot to say and you know,
you're not,
you're not spreading bad things.
You're,
you're,
you're having,
you have ideas and
you don't want what you son is really interesting because like in a one on one
competition sense that they're,
the only problem with that is that like a lot of life is competition and in
competition a lot of times a pace to be selfish.
Right.
You know,
there's a very interesting way of looking at life like in,
in,
in terms of looking at it like a competition or looking like it is as you have
to be competitive,
but at the same time we're all somehow or another a part of the same thing.
That's a weird sort of a differentiation that a lot of people have a really
difficult time.
You know,
it takes like a lot of life experience to sort of put that together.
Yeah.
You know,
and if you're a person who's like a competitive person,
especially at a young age,
it takes,
it's a lot of conditioning to get past the idea of like looking out 100% for
you,
only for you.
And like everybody else could potentially be an enemy or a,
an opponent now.
So it's,
uh,
I think for,
do you,
do you find that there's a lot of competition like amongst a fellow bands and a
lot of like weird shit that goes on?
Like,
you know,
I think if you look at it like that,
you're already at,
you're leading with a handicap,
you know,
because that's not what it's about for me.
I'll speak for myself.
I'm of course not right.
But I mean,
it's
not just a little bit of a,
Polo did this little bit of a jealous worlds that exists.
You know what I mean?
There's the world that we get to do what we want and create the music that we
want,
but then there's the world that we have to survive as a business.
You know what I mean?
And that is a competition.
But the,
the bands that,
if you were potentially to call them competition are usually people I really
admire.
So there's a,
there's a shift.
If you're going from a defensive standpoint,
you're already going to lose,
you know,
and I don't,
I don't feel safe that way.
That's like a,
that's a weird way to live your life,
you know?
And,
and so when you just embrace like,
like inspiration,
like you,
I love that you keep saying that we inspire you.
That's such an honor.
And I feel like that about people that could,
one could potentially call our competition,
but I don't view them that way because I respect them.
My friend Paul Mooney,
he's a standup comedian that's old school stand up comedian used to write for a
Richard Pryor back in the day.
Like how much is a great guy?
And one of the things,
you know,
he's like tell a bunch of young comedians once he's like,
go be entertained.
Just go out to go be in a tact.
Yeah.
You know,
and I didn't even think about that until I tell Paul said that.
And then now I like consciously go look to be entertained and that's swear.
I was so excited about seeing you
guys
were all bad.
I feel like that's what you're saying.
That'd be ability to be,
to compete without feeling threatened.
You know what I mean?
Because that's not,
well it'd be off the tiny or it can be a healthy thing.
I think it's a very helpful thing.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
It's like is listening to your old shit that sucks
cause it fucking gets you going.
God,
they'll fuck shit.
Ooh.
Dammit.
You know,
it's this,
this,
uh,
there's good in that man's good and everything.
Right?
Fuck,
I'm glad I met you guys.
All right,
so you got to play,
uh,
Angela does
for you.
Joe.
This is all free
floating.
Harry Massey.
Beep insanity.
Let's say
yes.
Hey.
Never span single day up.
Ah,
okay.
Yeah.
Yes.
Ben,
many yellow.
Yes.
Treated them the same as you
have a quick Ah,
and
this
is day
two of you.
Yeah.
His name.
Keep your hand on your chest.
Whisper
key.
Yeah,
maybe.
Oh,
home base that is admitted.
Ah,
no,
Matt.
Okay.
Just let your
sleep.
Sammy
and his knee.
Keep your hand on your chest.
It's best
d
outstanding.
Outstanding.
Less than you guys.
You guys are the shit.
This has been an honor and one of the funnest,
coolest podcast we've ever done.
God,
that was amazing.
Yeah,
it was really fun to do.
I was so,
I'm sorry if I talked too much.
I was hammered.
You guys was great.
I got a little mushy.
They're a little crazy.
I said some shit that I probably going to regret it.
And,
but not a spot it on my new chairs.
Joe,
I spotted a little
girl's gotta do what a girl's got to do.
Um,
listen,
this has been so much fun.
It's really been,
uh,
an unusual exercise in the use of the Internet and you know,
and how it all came together and it's so satisfying and fun.
Really interesting.
And I'm so glad you guys came on and anything we could ever do for you.
If you ever have anything you want to promote,
anything,
please come on anytime.
You're more than welcome you guys.
You guys are really cool.
Cool people wish you nothing but the best.
And you can get them online at Twitter,
at honey,
honey band at honey honey band,
no spaces.
You fucking freaks.
And uh,
is there a website?
Honey?
Honey,
band.com.
[inaudible] dot com
porn site.
Oh,
don't go to that.
Woopsies thank God our God ma.
That's,
we also also featuring pictures of ourselves.
Yeah,
you guys were on that one as well.
We should buy that.
You got to buy that site.
How much are they offering for it?
I have no idea,
but I know we don't have any money.
Yeah,
that's probably worth millions,
you know honey,
honey.com it's eventually you know someone from,
you know someone's going to know someone and they're going to say,
hey,
just go to honey honey.com you get all the details and they're going to be mad
at you.
What about that now?
Or they're going to think it's okay.
You know what?
You need to get anonymous on your side.
No,
don't do that honey.
honey.com is probably a legitimate business.
Will come in.
Ridiculous idea.
Was that entrepreneurship.
Go American honey,
honey,
band.com only honey
honey [inaudible] dot com and um,
and find them on Twitter and that's it.
Thanks to the flashlight for sponsoring our podcast.
Thank you.
We'll get you one if you want.
You could just you,
I think I'm okay for now.
Just like vibrate.
You'd like to taste it doesn't vibrate right then.
Would you like one?
We can get you one.
I'm not really sure what I should say.
Right.
That's a good call.
I like how you laid that.
That's exactly how you should have played it too much.
Um,
if you want one just seriously hall at me,
go to Joe rogan.net.
Click on the link for the flashlight and during the
codename Rogan.
You where else?
I ain't even fucking freak.
You don't have to sing too with a flashlight.
I have to do what I gotta do.
Dude,
I gotta get through this thing.
We're fine.
Thank you to on a.com.
O n.
N,
I t.
Go there.
Check out all of the different nootropics and Google nootropics.
If you're interested in this subject,
entering the code name Brogan.
If you want to buy some Alpha brain bitches,
what's up with that?
Have a brain.
Alvin is a cognitive enhancing some of them that I use on a daily basis and make
them talk so smoothly.
And during the Qa Rogan,
get yourself 10% off player.
Listen,
this has been a really fun podcast.
Thank you guys for coming out.
I really appreciate the fuck out of it.
Thank you guys at home.
I,
I appreciate the fuck out of Youtube ice house Friday.
One love you dirty bitches.
Icehouse Pasadena Friday,
get a flight,
get outta here.
Hurry up quick.
It's gonna sell out.
Go rotten.